on the 13th of October 1989 the town of
Danner Wisconsin was shaken by a seismic
event unlike anything they'd ever
experienced this might have been written
off as an earthquake Where not for one
disturbing Factor the ground shaking
event was accompanied by a huge Spike of
radioactivity with a strange phenomenon
happening a month before the Berlin Wall
was torn down during a period of the
Cold War that historians call the year
of Crisis it's easy to understand why
the people of Danner immediately assumed
the worst but the huge eruption they
felt wasn't the result of a nuclear bomb
going off the SCP Foundation was alerted
to the event in Danner when they picked
up a series of radio Transmissions
coming from just outside the town when
they arrived they found something
incredible like something out of a
sci-fi movie standing at the quake's
epicenter was a creature that looked to
be from another world standing two
meters tall and weighing almost 300
kilograms the being was green and brown
in color with a bulky humanoid body its
head was a different story though and
resembled a gigantic house fly with a
proboscis and huge stereoscopic eyes
surprisingly the strange creature did
not immediately go on a rampage instead
the being designated
scp-2273 appeared to be exhausted
injured and extremely malnourished it
offered no resistance at all to the
foundation containment team and it was
taken to site 17 without conflict while
the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
visitors from other worlds there was
something especially unusual about the
supposed alien Invader the doctors who
examined the creature and treated its
injuries found in appendage that seemed
to function as an organic radio
transmitter and large open wounds on its
shoulder blades and forearms where
further appendages had been ripped off
additionally while its insect-like
exoskeleton was mostly a uniform green
and brown pattern the creatures upper
arms and torso were dotted with a
variety of scars and markings that on
closer inspection looked like military
badges was this some kind of wounded
Intergalactic soldier who had been
stranded on Earth if it was then how
were the organic badges on this aliens
exoskeleton a near perfect match to
military badges worn by soldiers in the
Soviet Union even if they did reference
a unit that didn't officially exist
within the Soviet Army the scientists
were sure this alien wasn't an alien at
all underneath its exoskeleton was a
non-anomalous human being if that was
true then this was even more terrifying
than an extraterrestrial visitor the
scientists were sure that the USSR had
developed a new kind of organic armor
and this anomaly showing up in Wisconsin
was the result of a test on U.S soil
that had gone wrong if that was the case
then there was no telling how many more
of these exoskeletons were out there and
would need to be contained the
foundation had to act quickly and find
out more while
scp-2273 was recovering they called in
Dr Friedrich an on-site psychologist who
could speak several languages including
Russian Dr Friedrich would be tasked
with interrogating the SCP on his
Origins and the nature of the suit the
interview was conducted via AM radio
from a separate observation chamber as
the biological transmitter seemed to be
scp-2273's only method of communication
the interview began with Dr Friedrich
speaking to
scp-2273 in Russian only for 2273 to
respond that Dr friedrich's accent was
atrocious and requesting he used German
instead
scp-2273 who according to the organic
military patches on his body was named
Major Alexi bellatrov initially resisted
being interviewed he believed that he
was a prisoner of war being held by the
American Military according to him he
had been in the middle of battle and
that the Americans had killed his men
and left him for dead in in the
wilderness nothing that Dr Friedrich
told him that there was no war or that
the foundation was not affiliated with
the U.S government could convince him
otherwise and he refused to talk further
before a second interview was conducted
velotrov was given an old copy of the
level one researcher General debrief as
a way of helping him further understand
the nature of the foundation and his
containment belatrop was more
Cooperative after that though the
realization that he would most likely be
kept in containment for the rest of his
life caused him great distress and he
was unwilling to speak to Dr Friedrich
for another three days Dr Friedrich
didn't give up though and when bellatrop
finally opened up to the doctor he began
to tell him more and more bellatroft
told the doctor that when he was a child
Russia was hit by an American nuclear
warhead and that the Soviet Union
immediately retaliated the resulting
nuclear conflict which belatroff called
the war to end the world caused massive
Devastation and left most of the planet
Dangerously irradiated that is why he
had the exoskeleton it was to Shield him
from the radiation and allow him to
survive above ground unfortunately
velotrov knew very little about how the
suit was made or how it worked saying
that it was built by the engineers and
that it grew naturally over a period of
several years but bellatrov hadn't made
the decision himself it was his parents
who had volunteered him as a test
subject for the exoskeleton suit program
when he was still young hoping it would
give him a better chance at survival the
process of bonding the exoskeleton to
the human body was extremely painful but
according to balatrov its advantages far
outweighed the pain the suit not only
helped him survive in a nuclear
Wasteland but made him a better Soldier
the suit allowed him to lift and carry
up to 1200 kilograms gave him
stereoscopic vision and the organic
radio transmitter allowed him to
communicate with other soldiers across
long distances as well as listen in
non-encrypted enemy Transmissions the
wounds on his shoulders and arms where
it looked like appendages had been
ripped out were where his weapons and
Supply packs had previously been mounted
velotrov had been stationed with his men
in the area he was discovered when they
were attacked by American soldiers the
soldiers had ripped off bellatrop's
weapons and Supply pack and did the same
to all his men as well they were all
shocked with belatrop being spared for
the moment only because the Americans
had identified him as the commanding
officer suddenly there was a bright
flash of light and the American soldiers
vanished not only that but the landscape
changed where there had been a
post-nuclear wasteland before now there
were lush green trees injured and
disoriented bellatrov began sending
distress signals only to have those
signals intercepted by the SCP
Foundation the most interesting part of
belatron's story as far as the
foundation was concerned came during his
fourth interview when Dr Friedrich asked
him about the engine Engineers who had
designed the exoskeleton suit in
belladrov's own words they weren't truly
known to man until the years of the
Great War and the revolution the French
found them in buried cities where the
Western allies were digging their
trenches eventually they were made to
build weapons for the war by both sides
by his description these Engineers
didn't sound human but they were by no
means unknown to the SCP Foundation
bellatrov described the engineers as
humanoid nocturnal covered in fur and
possessing technology and intelligence
far beyond that of any human those
familiar with the foundation's history
might already know the engineers by
their Foundation designation of
scp-1000 or their more commonly known
name Bigfoot a quick rundown
scp-1000 are a species of intelligent
humanoid primates that lived alongside
Humanity in highly advanced cities until
their own technology was turned against
them not only were there cities wiped
off the face of the Earth but 70 percent
of their population was slaughtered and
the survivors were driven mad to the
point that their mental faculties were
no higher than those of a chimpanzee or
gorilla the SCP Foundation is tasked
with keeping them away from Human
contact in fear of what the creatures
would be able to do to humanity if they
ever regained their memories and full
mental function and rumors have been
spread about them possessing deadly
anomalous properties but evidently the
destruction of the scp-1000 species
never occurred in bellatrop's universe
or if it did it wasn't nearly as
complete in that timeline Humanity
regained contact with scp-1000 after
discovering their underground cities
sometime during World War one after this
discovery both Allied and Axis Powers
began recruiting them to build weapons
and their weapons played a role in both
the Russian Revolution and the second
world war it was because of these
technological advantages that the Cold
War escalated into what would become the
war to end all wars both sides were
armed with not only nuclear warheads but
highly Advanced radiation-proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the
conflict to continue even after the
total Destruction of the planet while
the humans fought above ground life
continued as normal for scp-1000 in
their underground cities as velotrov
noted they never wore the armor
themselves as they had no need to
venture above ground only soldiers wear
armor and this is not their War
belatroft continued to adjust to life in
containment and sitting for regular
interviews with Dr Friedrich he was
given the rations provided for humanoid
anomalies but in much larger quantities
as the suit required him to eat around 8
000 calories a day to keep it
functioning bellatrov also began taking
advantage of his ability to access the
foundation's library he would often read
or listen to classical music
particularly by the Russian composer
Tchaikovsky he seemed especially fond of
reading the time machine by H.G Wells no
surprise given he was able to directly
relate to the experience of living
through an apocalypse and being
transported to a strange timeline with
no way to return home but with little
else to occupy his time bellatrov began
to display symptoms consistent with
post-traumatic stress disorder reporting
in his now regular interviews with Dr
Friedrich that he was constantly
reliving memories of the battles he'd
fought and the lives he had taken in
combat the suit was making the problems
worse too it seemed it was as if he
could never forget as one of its
features was an ability to store and
replay memories this feature was
intended as a strategic Aid that would
allow commanding officers to more
effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but
outside of combat this only served to
force balatrov into reliving his most
painful memories again and again every
night as he tried to sleep he would see
the faces of his men their weapons torn
from their exoskeleton laying in the
dirt after being gunned down by the
enemy like many veterans bellatrov was
being hit all at once with the harsh
realities of War now that his brain
wasn't solely focused on keeping him
alive it had time to process all the
horrors he'd experienced he told Dr
Friedrich I trained alongside these men
for years before they put us back on the
surface since we were all young children
we were brothers and I gave them the
order to surrender and got them killed I
should have died with them while the
story of
scp-2273 ends here the story of Alexi
bellatrov
scp-2273-1 continues in 2018 bellatrobe
was allowed passage to volugrad Russia
as part of an anomaly reintegration
program while he was unable to secure
employment within the Russian government
as he had hoped he eventually was taken
in by a monastery and continued to write
letters to Dr Friedrich until
friedrich's eventual death from lymphoma
related complications there's plenty
more on the monastery the anomaly
reintegration program and what happened
to Major belatrave when he returned to
Russia but that will have to be a story
for Another Day cast your mind back to
the height of the Cold War the ever
accelerating nuclear arms race brought
us closer than ever before to making the
nightmare of nuclear Armageddon a
terrifying reality the two main parties
in this conflict are the United States
and Soviet Union each amassing huge
amounts of nuclear warheads and jumping
on any available Advantage they can over
their enemies what you may not know is
that in order to detect an impending
attack from the United States the
Soviets developed what would become
known to the West as the dead hand but
this experimental piece of technology
also had another name
scp-1984. it is no secret that the
Soviet Union feared the threat of U.S
nuclear strikes an invasion just as much
as the U.S feared an attack from them so
as
scp-1984 was created to act as a
deterrence mechanism specifically
against secure second strikes secure
second strikes were both a deterrent and
overwhelming concern during the Cold War
referring to a country's ability after
suffering an initial nuclear attack to
still retaliate firing on their enemy
and causing Untold damage with their own
arsenal of nuclear weapons the Soviet
Union knew that any action they made
that could be perceived as an attack on
United States soil would be threatened
with nuclear retaliation and that if
they fired First America would return
fire and potentially annihilate them
with a second strike
scp-1984 was to be an automated system
that would activate in response to the
destruction of the Soviets main command
and control structure given that the
Dead Hand was created during the 80s you
might be forgiven for expecting a
nuclear detection system built at this
point in history to consist of various
sensors connected to a computer network
but you have also so probably already
realized that if this was the case then
the foundation wouldn't be so interested
in it in actuality
scp-1984 is a fully autonomous entity
rather than a network of sensors for
detecting incoming nuclear strikes or a
computer capable of initiating a second
strike perhaps what makes the foundation
more interested in the Dead Hand is that
it is both self-aware and links
simultaneously to every single one of
Russia's nuclear launch sites not only
this but scp-1984 also has direct access
to every single one of the atomic
weapons stockpiled by the Soviet Union
during the Cold War and is capable of
launching intercontinental ballistic
missiles at a moment's notice in short
scp-1984 could very easily end
horrifyingly quickly trigger an all-out
nuclear war resulting in the extinction
of all life on Earth no wonder the
foundation considers the Dead Hand such
a massive threat
scp-1984 itself actually consists of the
preserved remains of a Russian soldier
by the name of Sergeant Marat chernikov
who was killed during the Soviet Afghan
war in 1982. most of the official
documentation of chernikov's existence
has been expunged by the Russian
Federation and he is only referred to in
fragmented documents recovered by the
foundation that referred to a project
December these remains serve as the
location of a semi-sentient
Consciousness that has been classified
as
scp-1984-01 when it remains dormant and
is not interfered with
scp-1984-01 has the ability to receive
and process any signal broadcast to it
and is able to decipher information
combined in any signal it picks up
however when global Military tensions
start to climb especially when those
tensions affect the Russian Federation
or what were once the satellite states
of the former Soviet Union The Entity
begins to manifest itself in the
physical world and usually in various
strange and different ways
scp-1984-01 has been known to appear in
the real world in forms such as a
humanoid outline or a bright red Specter
taking the shape of a child with its
legs cut off regardless of which shape
it appears in it is when the Dead Hand
manifests in a more physical form that
the wider scope of its abilities become
clear as mentioned previously it can
influence and even launch nuclear
weapons overriding their command systems
and bypassing launch sequences after
appearing fully
scp-1984-01 will travel at speeds of up
to 140 kilometers an hour directly to
the nearest military installation
capable of launching intercontinental
ballistic missiles once it reaches its
destination
scp-1984-01 will immediately attempt to
override the necessary systems to
initiate a launch after firing missiles
at their predetermined targets
scp-1984-01 will hastily travel to
another facility housing nuclear
ornaments repeating the process until it
has successfully launched all of
Russia's Atomic weapons when engaged the
physical manifestation of scp-1984 is
highly aggressive and will lethally
defend itself against anyone that it
observes trying to interfere with it or
stop it from causing a nuclear launch
the entity has displayed the ability to
disrupt the nervous system causing
excruciating pain and debilitating
damage to human beings it's only known
weakness if any is a susceptibility to
microwave radiation although exposure to
this does not seem to cause any lasting
damage to
scp-1984. instead only temporarily
disorienting its physical form as for
the origins of scp-1984 the Soviet
Union's official liaison with the SCP
Foundation offered some clarity on this
ironically during early 1984 the liaison
a doctor named Sergey described
information regarding the Dead Hand as
being of grave importance to the
continued survival of the human race
seeing as he was referring to an enemy
that could single-handedly launch the
Soviet Union's entire nuclear Arsenal he
certainly had a point a top secret
Conference was held in Sarajevo between
the foundation's o5 council and
officials from both the USSR and the
United States using the 1984 Winter
Olympics as cover avoiding too many
questions about several Nations
high-ranking State officials being in
the same place at once the o5 council
was then given full in-depth information
about the Dead Hand something they had
previously assumed was a more
conventional form of nuclear deterrence
scp-1984 was far more and worse far out
of the control of the Russian government
it was revealed that the entity had been
designated outside the original
specifications given to those who
developed it initially the Soviets had
intended for the Dead Hand to be solely
used as a secure second strike response
if the leaders of the Soviet Union were
killed
scp-1984 would react in kind to Russia's
enemies launching back all of the ussr's
nuclear missiles in retaliation this is
more likely where the Dead Hand nickname
comes from hearkening to the idea of a
dead man's switch picture that you had
been mortally wounded by your worst
enemy shot in the stomach and laying on
the ground rapidly bleeding out you know
that there is no chance you will survive
but you cannot afford to let your enemy
get away what they don't know is that
you rigged the entire building around
you both with explosives with your dying
breath you activate the Detonator
assuring your own and your enemies
Mutual destruction Kaboom then curtains
for both of you the pressing issue and
the reason this secret Summit between
the USSR USA and SCP Foundation was held
was that scp-1984 was no longer
interested in just just waiting for
Russia to be attacked and only reacting
after the fact instead the entity's
physical form was trying to preemptively
strike at the enemies of the motherland
attempting to activate nuclear launches
and send Atomic weapons to destroy the
United States France West Germany and
the People's Republic of China in other
words the Dead Hand was eager to get a
head start at causing total nuclear
Annihilation not to mention potentially
killing millions and reducing Target
countries to little more than irradiated
craters Awash with deadly nuclear
fallout both the Soviet Union and the
United States begged the SCP Foundation
to intervene and contain
scp-1984 and under the direction of the
o5 council they stepped in to take
direct control of the situation
establishing new containment procedures
in the hopes of keeping
scp-1984 from hitting as many launch
buttons as it could find the embalmed
remains that seemed to create the
manifestations of the Dead Hand and city
were held securely in an armed
containment complex near vercoy youngsk
part of the Saka Republic within the
Russian Federation
scp-1984 was placed within a standard
humanoid containment cell which was
itself held within a faraday cage a type
of enclosure constructed with or covered
in conductive material designed to block
electromagnetic fields this was done to
block any external broadcast signals
from reaching
scp-1984 and thus causing it to manifest
its other form if it learned of an
impending attack on Russia even a
fictional one perhaps as a part of a
television broadcast as part of the dead
hands Containment all signals broadcast
near its cage are to be monitored and
only broadcast featuring doctored
information would reach the entity
thankfully to the work of the SCP
foundation's information control team
scp-1984 is drip fed a stream of
carefully fabricated information using
on-site equipment and Facilities a team
of military historians economists actors
and Soviet media Specialists the
information control team have created an
ongoing narrative wherein the Cold War
never ended through falsified radio and
television broadcast made to look like
era appropriated news organizations they
managed to keep
scp-1984 convinced that the nuclear
stalemate between the Soviet Union and
United States is still ongoing
unfortunately sometimes information from
The Real World is able to bleed through
an incident involving scp-1984 occurred
on August 8 1984 and almost brought
forth a full-scale nuclear war while
preparing for a campaign speech the 40th
President of the United States Ronald
Reagan uttered the following joke I am
pleased to tell you today that I've
signed legislation that will Outlaw
Russia forever we begin bombing in five
minutes naturally thousands of media
Outlets reported on this but signals of
those broadcasts including recordings of
the president's remark made their way to
as
scp-1984 Foundation researchers were
both unsure of how these Transmissions
breached the Faraday cage surrounding
the Dead Hand and were unable to prevent
what happened next hearing what I could
only assume was a genuine declaration of
war the manifestation of the
scp-1984-01 entity happened immediately
after Reagan's words reached its
containment cell this time the entity
appeared as a semi-transparent woman
withered in blue wearing traditional
pashtun dress armed Personnel guarding
scp-1984's cage engaged The Entity
causing it to retaliate lashing out and
attacking any that stood in its way one
captain and two privates that suffered
the brunt of scp-1984's offensive
capabilities began bleeding heavily from
their ears seizing violently most
gruesomely of all a liquid leaked from
their eyes and nose believed to have
been cerebrospinal fluid while armed
Personnel attempted to use microwave
emitting Weaponry to slow the anti down
the information control team was
frantically trying to record a new
falsified broadcast in the hopes that
scp-1984 would cease its hostilities and
the entity would dissipate before it was
able to travel at high speed to any
nearby Soviet nuclear facilities and
begin bombarding the United States their
first attempt to record a new broadcast
that would result in a cessation of
scp-1984 Slaughter of its guards was
interrupted when a nearby wall collapsed
desperate to recontain the creature the
information control team tried to film
the broadcast a second time and
succeeded although one of the actors
portraying a news reader suffered a
stroke and had to be edited out to
convince the Dead Hand of its supposed
authenticity what followed was a short
news clip clarifying that Russia's
politburo was in on President Reagan's
joke including old footage of the ussr's
general secretary Constantine chernenko
confirming that the Soviet Union's
nuclear forces were not on high alert
miraculously after 50 18 more minutes of
sustained fighting with guards
scp-1984's physical manifestation began
to disappear gradually dematerializing
while it seemed to attack with far less
intensity eventually containment was
re-established at the cost of the deaths
of 17 members of foundation staff both
gods and researchers a further Aid
however suffered traumatic brain
injuries that left them all permanently
disabled the one upside is that this
incident Remains the only time as CP
1984 has ever breached its containment
and caused harm to others and
considering that it could very well have
launched Russia's nuclear Arsenal the
casualties could easily have been much
higher so remember folks don't joke
about nuclear weapons especially if
you're the president you never know what
anomalies lurking in the bodies of dead
Russian soldiers might be listening and
if they are you'd better hope they have
a sense of humor the year is 1939. it's
the dead of night in ping Fang a
district of the Harbin prefecture in
Japanese Imperial occupied China a
squadron of over a hundred Chinese
Rebels led by Lieutenant Wong Wei
clutching Bergman MP18 machine guns
hurry through the streets towards their
destination the bioweapons lab operated
by Unit 731 and monstrous terrifying
Japanese Surgeon General Shiro ishi it
is a mission of Liberation and revenge
if you know anything about Unit 731 just
hearing the name will send a chill down
your spine just as it did for the
Chinese soldiers hoping to perform a
surprise assault on the unit's complex
of Horrors rumors had spread from the
Chinese prisoner years of war taken
there and the knowledge of the horrible
things happening to their countrymen
inside that building made their blood
boil with white hot Fury their mission
was simple they would launch an attack
on the complex when the unit least
expected it save as many prisoners as
they could while also taking revenge on
as many unit soldiers as they could get
their hands on but what the brave
Soldiers didn't know is that they were
in for battle they couldn't hope to win
because what they were fighting was not
in any traditional sense human they were
about to go toe-to-toe with
scp-4007 an elite group of anomalous
Japanese super soldiers known as the
Ping Fang five a name spoken in fear by
their enemies and victims For What
Little Time both remained alive the
Chinese Rebels were hiding in a stand of
trees outside the Fortress waiting for
the right moment to strike when the Ping
Fang 5 suddenly beat them to the punch
and descended upon them the plan was
thrown into chaos when the trees burst
into flames without so much as a hint of
artillery being fired the soldiers all
hardened Men of War began to grow scared
but then they saw something even more
terrifying standing there amongst the
Flames first lieutenant mitso Kitano
also known as lightning bolt or
scp-4007-1 to the foundation one of his
hands was wreathed in blue Sparks of
electricity and the others he wielded a
type 14 nambu pistol Lieutenant Kitano
continued his attack using his anomalous
lightning to blow away Soldier after
Soldier when the shocked Rebels tried to
return fire they found that they
couldn't land a single shot Gaetano
dodged every bullet the second wave of
the assault came from behind as the
rebels tried to flee katano's round
private Takashi Honda also known as the
ogre or
scp-4007-2 charged Into The Fray he
effortlessly wielded a type 11 machine
gun can rain bullets down upon his
unsuspecting foes they shot back at him
but the bullets seemed to just bounce
off his skin he wasn't bothered by them
in the slightest he just smiled and
continued firing the rebels quickly
realized that the whole thing had been a
trap but what had given them away as if
On Cue one of their own soldiers turned
and began firing on his fellow Soldiers
with his MP18 this man wasn't a rebel in
fact he wasn't even Chinese it was
Corporal jochiro Ida also known as the
fox or
scp-4007-3 how could he have possibly
infiltrated the Squadron the answer is
simple he's an anomalously brilliant
liar in fact it's impossible to not
believe a single thing that Corporal Ida
says making him a true expert in
Espionage not a single one of the other
Rebels ever had a chance of sniffing him
out before the doomed Mission if this
betrayal surprised them then what came
next must have seemed like something out
of a nightmare Lieutenant Wong Wei the
man who'd spearheaded the entire Mission
turned and began picking off his own
troops with his pistol the surviving
soldiers didn't understand have
Lieutenant gone mad they tried to shoot
him but just like the others he dodged
effortlessly and continued to murder
them that's because he wasn't Lieutenant
Wong way at all way had been murdered in
the forest earlier that night and
replaced by private Terror nishimura
also known as
scp-4007-5 or the shapeshifter the Ping
Fang 5 had infiltrated and compromised
the mission from before it had even
begun they never even stood a chance
during the chaos of the massacre a few
of the rebels had managed to escape
running through a nearby clearing into a
Thicket of trees if they could survive
then perhaps they could regroup and
leave a second assault on another day
they had no help of survival during a
head-on conflict with these anomalous
super soldiers they needed to get away
and form a new strategy but gunshots
started ringing out through the forest
tearing into their bodies and dropping
the men one by one they tried to return
fire but they couldn't even see who was
shooting at
it seemed to come from all directions
the rebels dying thoughts were that the
trees around them must have been
crawling with Japanese troops the
reality was even more frightening it was
only one man private Shigeru Matsui
codenamed smoke for this ability to
become invisible at will to the
foundation he's known as
scp-4007-4 the last member of the Ping
Fang five the deadliest troops in the
entire Imperial Japanese Army but unlike
many of the biological anomalies
cataloged by the SCP Foundation the Ping
Fang five were not born they were made
in case you aren't familiar with the
infamous Unit 731 and their horrifying
complex in ping Fang this unit was the
secret Department of the Japanese Army
ordered into existence by Emperor
Hirohito himself for one Sinister
purpose researching chemical and
biological weapons for the Japanese
Imperial Army their leader the Surgeon
General Shiro ishi was essentially given
blanket permission to do whatever he
deemed necessary in order to achieve
results for his Emperor and his Nation
ishi took that directive and ran with it
unleashing pseudoscientific evil on a
level matched only by the Nazi
extermination camps in Europe
experimental weapons and horrific
diseases were tested on captured Chinese
civilians political dissidents and
prisoners of war thousands of people met
horrific ends through execution
experimentation and vivisection which is
the dissection of a subject that is
still very much alive how does this
relate to the Ping Fang 5 and scp-4007
it all comes back to a top secret
project overseen by ishi himself project
shinka while Unit 731 was established in
1935. in 1937 they began working in
collaboration with the Imperial Japanese
anomalous matters examination agency
think of it as Imperial Japan's hyper
nationalist answer to the SCP Foundation
they had become aware of the exist
instance of anomalous individuals in
Imperial controlled territories and
generally she wanted to know whether the
powers manifested in these anomalous
individuals could be induced in others
through forced organ removal and
transplantation to test this hypothesis
ishi had the Japanese secret police
Roundup anomalous individuals in
Imperial territory on mass they were
subjected to massive sections with the
intention of isolating and removing
anomalous organs it was an act so
positively genocidal in proportion that
East Asia had statistically fewer
anomalous humans than they should to
this day ishi's intention was to
transplant the organs into loyal
volunteers from the Japanese military in
order to create an unbeatable military
force perfect soldiers who would win the
war for them the vast majority of these
Twisted experiments were complete
failures leading to the higher ups at
Unit 731 almost writing project shinka
off as a waste of time and canceling the
whole thing but there were soon June 5
notable exceptions the very scary
individuals you've already met not only
did every member of the Ping Fang 5 end
up with a specific anomalous superpower
as a result of the experiments they also
experienced incredible anomalous prowess
across the board members of the five
boast extended longevity meaning they
rarely show their age enhance physical
abilities including faster reflexes
incredible senses and immense physical
strength they also appear to have
advanced mental development displaying
phenomenal tactical and strategic
reasoning as well as the ability to
effortlessly learn read and speak
multiple languages like Japanese English
Mandarin Chinese Russian and German of
course Japan eventually lost the war but
the Ping Fang 5 had no intentions of
ending their fight they continued their
missions long after Japan formally
surrendered causing chaos and violence
across East Asia after several
unsuccessful engagements with isolate
members of the Ping Fang 5 leading to
the deaths of many Foundation agents and
civilians the foundation formed mobile
task force 551 AKA MacArthur's dogs an
elite group of operatives trained for
the specific mission of Bringing Down
the Ping Fang five while the hunt rages
on three of the five are already dead
scp-4007-1 mitsuo Kitano the man who can
unleash bursts of electricity met his
end in Burma in 1948. during a procedure
called operation Smokehouse 551 engage
katano in combat in the jungle as was
one of his trademark techniques he
attempted to use his electricity powers
to burn down the jungle and Escape
during the chaos however the foundation
operatives surrounded and boxed him in
he couldn't escape and when the fires
were put out he was found dead on the
ground the apparent cause of death was
smoke inhalation
scp-4007-2 Takashi Honda the man with
bullproof skin died in 1957 in the
Philippines 551 engaged him in combat an
emission dubbed operation home wrecker
which culminated in them calling down an
air strike on him in the aftermath Honda
was found dead but his cause of death
was determined as having been from a
powerful electric shock and finally
scp-4007-3 jojiro Ida the man with the
silver tongue was found dead a year
later in 1958 his corpse was discovered
in his room in GUI Yang Southern China
he appeared to have been strangled to
death and interestingly there was
evidence that he tried to engage in the
shootout with his killer but hadn't
succeeded in preventing his own murder
all these circumstances were somewhat
mysterious but the foundation didn't
investigate them much further after the
bodies were tagged and bagged
scp-4007-5 teronishimura the
shapeshifter is still on the run today
while
scp-4007-4 Shigeru Matsui The Invisible
Man is doing just the opposite he lives
in Sarawak Malaysia and works in open
cooperation with the SCP Foundation to
help track down the fifth member of the
Ping Fang five not much has changed in
the 64 years since the death of George
it seemed like the search for
scp-4007-4 had gone cold until a
foundation archival clerk found
something suspicious the original paper
copy of the scp-4007 document which was
dated a year before the foundation had
supposedly discovered the existence of
scp-4007 as the archival worker dug
further they found a number of
unsettling discoveries that alter the
true meaning of
scp-4007 in the original paper documents
each dead member of the Ping Fang 5 had
organs missing and each subsequent
member's death involved a power
possessed by a former member two was
electrocuted and three's gun was useless
as the killer had been wearing two's
Bulletproof Skin who was behind this why
and most importantly of all how now had
this all been forgotten through more
digging the foundation discovered the
truth about
scp-4007-4 his powers weren't
invisibility they were anti-memetic he
can make people forget him at will
essentially editing their memories so he
could do whatever he wanted without
detection like for example murdering his
team members and stealing their powers
they even managed to find an archive
letter from four to three begging for
his help in fighting some kind of
unknown monster something that would
require their combined powers to face
whether they ended up being as five
separate men or one man with all their
powers this whole time
scp-4007-4 had been playing the
foundation like a fiddle using their
resources to help him track down the
final member of the Ping Fang fine to
recruit him into one final mission or
murder him and steal his powers but that
still leaves one question what is this
Mission what is this monster the
foundation managed to find out at least
partially they charted the death
locations of each of the three dead ping
Fang members and the living location of
scp-4007-4 and discovered something
amazing four of the five points on a
perfect Pentagon centering on the South
China Sea the foundation also estimated
that the Pentagon would reveal the
location of
scp-4007-5 at the final point but his
location isn't nearly as interesting as
what resides at the center of this
massive geographical Pentagon Foundation
divers discovered huge numbers of sunken
Japanese battleships down planes and
thousands of Bones littering the seabed
based on the damages to these vessels it
was clear that they hadn't been shocked
or blown up no they had been torn apart
by something obscenely huge and Powerful
underneath the water the Pentagon a
significant shape and sorcery is likely
a massive Supernatural container ritual
keeping whatever unspeakable horror is
lurking under the ground there from
escaping a containment ritual that could
only be maintained by five special
individuals in five special places it
was in this moment that the foundation
Came Upon a truly horrifying Revelation
they had misjudged the intentions of
project shinka it was never about
creating assets for the war against the
Allies it was about a war against
something else entirely something much
more dangerous than and deadly than the
squabbles between men it was about the
entity that lurked below a creature that
nobody understood and that no
conventional weapon can fight and if the
ritual is ever broken and the Beast is
allowed to rise the Ping Fang 5 will be
the very least of our problems welcome
back comrade the case of
scp-2273 also known as major Alexi
bellatrov has sparked your imagination
and you need to know more but even if
you're not familiar with the major his
story all you need to know is that it's
one of War tragedy and Alternate
Dimensions he first appeared in the town
of Danner Wisconsin on the 13th of
October
1989. during an unprecedented seismic
event when he was first discovered the
foundation researchers assumed that he
was an extraterrestrial being on account
of his Advanced organic exoskeleton in a
surprising move for such an imposing
creature bellatrov gave himself up to
Foundation agents without a fight major
belatrave was then impounded in
Foundation containment site 17 where he
was interrogated thoroughly over a
series of interviews the foundation
ascertained that bellatrov came from an
alternate timeline where Russia and the
US are locked in a so-called war to end
the world thanks to Advanced military
technology given to them by
scp-1000 bellatrov had nearly escaped
execution at the hands of American
soldiers
appeared in our timeline now he is a
prisoner of the advanced suit that
formally kept him alive but his story
isn't over The Last Remnant of a cold
war turned hot has plenty left to teach
us something that you need to understand
about the SCP Foundation before we go
any further is that it doesn't only
exist in every nation across the globe
it also exists in every Splinter reality
across the Multiverse and these Splinter
realities offer a countless multitude of
tales of different places different
people and different times today's tale
concerns major belatrav's future in a
universe where the secrecy of the
foundation is broken and the anomalous
world needs to find a way to fit in with
our own the year was 2018 like many
humanoid anomalies that the foundation
was holding in this timeline bellatrov
was released from containment he was no
longer an SCP he was now a mere Person
of Interest free to move around as he
pleased but this didn't mean bellatrol
was about to enjoy a quiet life on easy
street he was still an interdimensional
Refugee from a broken alternate World
thankfully there was a certain group
willing to help the Mana charitable
Foundation this anomalous charity has
been involved in a number of strange
cases investigated by the foundation
before and now they were going to lend a
hand to Major belatroff thanks to their
anomaly reintegration project Mana was
able to transport bellatrov back to his
home of volugrad in Russia there he
became something of a national celebrity
making headlines across the country
sitting down for interviews on every
Russian talk show and even being offered
book deals but as a former military man
bellatrov was eager to return to
government life and run for a government
position however this ambition didn't go
very far belatrave was rejected by all
the government bodies he applied to even
Vladimir Putin wasn't eccentric enough
to want an insectosoid cyborg from a
another dimension in this cabinet
bellatrov endured a rough two years in
volagraph he was treated more like a
sideshow freak than a human being people
didn't want to rent apartments to him
and he was never able to find permanent
employment even entry-level jobs
rejected him nobody wanted to get food
served to them by what looked to be a
seven-foot monster and he seemed equally
ill-suited to help Russian women find
the right perfume in department stores
in April of 2020 bellatrov had finally
had enough he contacted the Mana
charitable Foundation once again and
asked to be relocated they told him that
some religious institutions in the area
including the Eastern Clockwork Orthodox
Church were accepting and housing
anomalous refugees not long after this
bellatrov truly fell off of the SCP
foundation's radar but one former
Foundation operative was well aware of
major bellatrov's fate it's 2021 Dr
Friedrich the site 7 teen anomaly
psychologist who'd conducted all the
initial interviews with bellatrov all
the way back in 1989 started receiving
letters from him there was no indication
as to his true location and they
appeared to have been handled by a man
of charitable Foundation mail carrier in
Russia but Dr Friedrich was happy to
hear from an old friend nonetheless due
to a career of working near highly
radioactive anomalies like bellatrov Dr
Friedrich was suffering from terminal
lymphoma it seemed almost like an act of
Divine Providence that bellatrov's
letters would come to him so close to
the end the two began a correspondence
and it was only after Dr friedrich's
eventual death that the letters came to
the SCP foundation's attention it was
from this final correspondence that the
foundation was able to answer the big
question whatever happened to Major
Alexi belatrov in his first letter to Dr
Friedrich belatroff thanked him
profusely he knew that Dr Friedrich had
been a crucial part of him gaining
freedom from the foundation and credited
the therapeutic techniques taught to him
by Dr Friedrich with keeping him alive
and sane to this day bellatrov expressed
a mix of Amazement at this Brave New
World and a sense of profound weariness
as a man eternally locked into a weapon
of War he felt unsuited to a world in
peacetime he almost missed the scorched
irradiated Rush of his home Dimension
but most of all he missed site 17. he
missed Dr Friedrich he missed some of
his fellow anomalies like scp-507 the
teleporting man and
scp-163 the spacecraft he even missed
the Simplicity of being contained he
hoped that Dr Friedrich would write back
in his second letter bellatrop began
detailing his experience with the
Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church
despite growing up in a highly atheistic
communist environment bellatrov became
enamored with the ways of the church he
found them to be highly accepting of him
in spite of his unfortunate
circumstances they displayed freedom in
their faith that bellatrov had never
encountered before and he was eager to
be a part of it with the help of Dr
Friedrich velotrov was also sending
letters to some of his fellow freed
anomalies he's signed off by saying that
he had even started praying something
he'd never considered before the next
letter sent in 2027 struck a much more
somber tone it was sent shortly after
belatroft discovered Dr friedrich's
diagnosis he wanted to return and see
the doctor one more time but the Mana
charitable Foundation wouldn't allow him
to return to site 17 believing he had
been abused during his time there
belladrov gave Frederick his prayers and
well wishes and asked for a number
through which he could contact his
ailing old friend by the time the next
letter arrived in 2034 bellatrov had
become a fully fledged member of the
Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church he
referred to the other Monks at the
monastery as his brothers and sisters he
seemed to have finally found a true home
there and the others fondly referred to
him by the nickname Father anphil but
the True Heart of the letter is
bellatrov's deep concern for Dr
friedrich's Health notably in this
letter he often refers to Dr Friedrich
by his first name Thomas as though to
emphasize the urgency of the message
after the deaths of several of the
anomalies that bellatrov considered
friends he stated that he couldn't
handle losing anyone else his letter
ends with a poignant passage you may be
unmarried Dr Friedrich but you are not
on love you have to be strong for me you
have to be strong for yourself if you're
ever worried that you cannot find the
strength to continue think of the garden
you'll plant this spring I'd like to
share gardening photos with you again
not many of my brothers and sisters here
appreciate the simple beauty of a flower
bed or the effort that goes into growing
a patch of vegetables it's a beauty I'd
like to continue to share trust in the
power of Our Lord Thomas and thrust in
the power of modern medicine God is
smiling on you please be strong with
love and prayers Alexi belletrov this
letter arrived on the 15th of February
2034. sadly Dr Friedrich had already
passed away four days earlier he never
got to see Alexi's final letter and it
truly was his final letter with nobody
left for him in the world major
bellatrov stopped sending any
correspondence what we know about the
final years of belatron's life all comes
from a few scattered journal entries
translated from Russian after his
passing they provide clues as to the
kind of life he lived during the 29
years the foundation could not account
for his whereabouts and his actions the
first entry written on January 7 2035
paints a grim picture of bellatrobe
feeling broken and isolated in the
monastery he wrote today is the day that
our Monastery celebrates the birth of
our Lord however I feel no desire to
celebrate all of my friends in this
world are dead my brothers and sisters
are partaking in some celebration
outside my dormitory all of the the
required ceremonies are complete neither
they nor whatever is happening out there
will lighten my mood bellatrov also
wrote about losing the Comfort he once
had in his faith and his doubts about
whether he would be able to recapture
that Comfort but he had survived greater
traumas than this and he would continue
to press on as the months turned to
years and the years turned to decades
velotrov climbed through the ranks of
the monastery seeing as the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church practically
worshiped the concepts of
industrialization and mechanization the
fact that bellatrov was permanently
encased in a biomechanical exoskeleton
probably made him seem even more Pious
to his holy Brethren the final piece of
evidence collected by the foundation
Into The Life and Times of Alexi
bellatrov came just over 20 years later
in a final address written to comfort
his followers in preparation for his own
death bellatrov recounted the details of
his own life being born into a world of
fire death and mushroom
than his life being suddenly saved by
forces Beyond his control only to place
him into containment for almost 30 years
it was only after accepting the
teachings of the church and accepting
the Clockwork Goddess that he felt he
was truly free from his past in this
final note bellatrov lay out some of the
teachings of his new religion the belief
in a great mechanized goddess who
planned all of reality according to
balotrov everything in her design fits
together perfectly like cogs in a
machine turning and twisting in unison
to create an ideal world he hoped to be
forgiven for the many violent sins he
committed in this military life and that
his contributions to this new world were
valuable at the very end of his address
bellatrov wrote I do not believe that my
time in this world is much longer
brothers and sisters when my time of
judgment comes do not mourn me I would
rather you remember these words the
goddess is most pleased with those who
see kind non-violent resolution to their
problems because a machine whose gears
grind against each other is a machine
that cannot work see truth but also
compassion the words are only words seek
out truth within them God bless you all
father Anvil a month after authoring
this statement records indicate that
Alexi belatrav was found dead in his
room having passed away peacefully in
his sleep from natural causes he lived A
Warrior's life but died a humble
priest's death the true tragedy in The
Strange Life of major Alexi belletrov is
how little Choice he had in his
circumstances but thanks to this tale we
know he did what he could with the life
he was given his remains lay within the
graveyard at the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodoxy Monastery where he spent the
last years of his life with a life as
difficult as his own we can only imagine
he is glad to finally rest history is
often the greatest teacher by looking at
the past we can learn from it with the
benefit of hindsight such as in the
early 20th century when the entire
planet was in the grip of a horrifying
War at the time this conflict was often
referred to as the Great War although
there was little grade about it others
knew it as the war to end all wars the
largest armed engagement the world had
known although it would not be the last
today with that hindsight we just
mentioned we know it as World War one in
June 1914 an Archduke of Austria was
shot dead by a Serbian assassin and as a
result of the complicated treaties
forged between various Nations soon much
of the world was involved in the war
that started out as little more than a
scuffle between neighbors the horrors of
trench warfare the Carnage caused by the
earliest chemical weapons and armored
tanks left a permanent and last testing
scar on the world's history one still
mourned and remembered to this day the
advances in chemical and mechanized
Warfare that took place during World War
One range from the use of chemicals like
tear gas used to disable targets to more
lethal compounds like mustard gas and of
course this was the first war to
introduce tanks to the battlefield
although these were clumsy and
cumbersome to begin with it was arguably
the Advent of the first world war that
forced many advancements in armored
Warfare it was the belief of many
individuals on all sides that if the
Great War was made too gruesome and
horrific to continue it would come to
its natural end this of course did not
happen only encouraging each participant
of World War One to continue advancing
their Weaponry but what if there were
weapons developed during World War one
that were too dangerous to be deployed
with every side looking for advantage
over their adversaries what if some
turned to the unethical even the
anomalous to gain the upper hand in the
war introducing
scp-186 otherwise known as to end all
wars try to imagine Weaponry that was so
incredibly Advanced for the mid-1910s
yet so horribly and unjustifiably cruel
worse than gas that can cause blisters
to form not only on the skin but also
inside the lungs more advanced than
armored vehicles with mounted machine
guns crawling across no man's land it's
hard to picture something that could be
more devastating than that especially
for the time period but a good measure
of a weapon's destructive power is
usually found in the damage it leaves in
its wake in this case
scp-186 is exactly that not the
anomalous weapons themselves but the
sight of a battle that took place
between the 24th of July and the 13th of
August in 1917. the event became known
as the Battle of husseinatin woods but
you won't find any mention of it in the
history books any and all records of the
battle have been secretly expunged by
the SCP Foundation and their own archive
is now the only place where someone can
find the details of what happened over
those few weeks the engagement took
place between the German Imperial Army
and forces belonging to Russia's
provisional government a small Skirmish
in comparison to the enormity of many
battles of the first world war so what
happened at the Battle if you see it in
woods to make it so horrible that it had
to be stricken from the historical
record for that we have to go back to
hesitan a small settlement in Western
Ukraine in July of 1917 the surviving
remnants of a Russian division had been
scattered the Germans counter-attacked
against the kerninsky offensive had
driven the Russian troops to the dense
forest that surrounded the town of
ecitin you might be forgiven for
thinking that the outnumbered Russian
Force was decimated by almost 500 German
soldiers pursuing them but you would be
very very wrong as the opposing forces
met they engaged each other in a
fearsome battle but this was unlike any
encounter that had taken place over the
course of World War One or ever would
again both sides were armed with
anomalous Weaponry possessing technology
Beyond any that had ever been seen at
the time to this day the SCP Foundation
has been baffled by these weapons even
with their unique understanding of the
anomalous Foundation researchers had
been unable to replicate any of them and
instead keeps them secured in the
Munitions wing of psych-23 all under the
designation of
scp-186-1 among the recovered instances
of
scp-186-1 is a highly modified skoda M
1909 machine gun however rather than
behaving like a standard firearm this
gun would cause rapid forming growths
not unlike tumors to appear within the
body of its targets another was
concertina wire a form of spiraled razor
wire commonly used in trenches only this
wire was coated in an unknown compound
that caused permanent hallucination
whenever the wire cut a person and
allowed the hallucinogen to enter their
bloodstream a number of rifle cartridges
were also found littered around
scp-186 sounds pretty normal for a first
World War battlefield right except these
cartridges were not filled with
gunpowder like you would expect them to
be instead they inexplicably contain
human bone ground into powder the
purpose of this ammunition or how it was
manufactured is still unknown to the SCP
Foundation as if a gun that causes
tumors and hallucination triggering wire
weren't bad enough Foundation
researchers also found a number of
grenades used by the troops at the site
of scp-186 these were British Empire
standard issue number 27 seven grenades
but they contained a unique anomalous
gas that was capable of passing through
any and all filters gas masks were
developed during World War One to
protect soldiers from mustard and tear
gas on the battlefield but these masks
only offered basic filtration by today's
standards even so the gas contained in
these grenades was strong enough to
negate any and all filtration systems
but that was far from its worst quality
did this unknown gas choke troops not
quite did it disable them like tear gas
in a way yes but this gas did so by
making any Soldier exposed to it
experience the sensation of having their
bodies set on fire constantly also
recovered at scp-186 were the remains of
some form of explosive and it is
believed by the foundation that it was
detonated at the culmination of the
battle of Houston Woods causing
approximately a third of the battle's
total casualties Foundation research
teachers estimate that almost 300
civilians were either caught in the
blast or died as a result of the
crossfire between the German and Russian
forces the soldiers involved were also
all permanently incapacitated or killed
or at least almost all of them so where
did these anomalous weapons come from
and why were they used just in this
battle not throughout the first world
war according to records kept from the
public by the SCP Foundation the German
troops in the Houston Woods were
accompanied by a Hungarian advisor to
their military named Matthias nemes
under his orders they specifically
targeted and tracked the Russian
division that was retreating from them
who were similarly accompanying a French
scientist Dr Jean tahand it was these
two men nemes and Durand who were
responsible for arming the Germans and
Russians with their arsenals of
anomalous weapons they had ensured that
their inventions of death had only
received limited Manufacturing and had
intentionally joined opposing sides of
the war effort to test their Creations
in real Combat in other words it appears
that the Hond and the Maze has been
working together since the beginning of
the war and the troops they were with
had been manipulated into taking part in
a big test these soldiers were just as
unlucky as the civilians caught in the
crossfire today the SCP Foundation has
established an automated security
perimeter around the site of scp-186
preventing access to anyone unless
authorized everything within the
perimeter is frequently patrolled and
observed by security Personnel why the
need for so much security at an Old
Battleground given the damage caused by
the use of so many anomalous weapons
including those that the foundation was
unable to recover the area of scp-186
has become a hot spot for unusual
happenings even long after the battle of
Houston Woods ended these anomalies
include abnormal environmental or
whether other conditions for example all
the trees in the southwestern portion of
the former Battlefield died and
decomposed at an accelerated rate in
1923 while the temperature dropped to a
permanent minus 15 degrees Celsius four
years later but yet there was never any
snowfall then there were the sounds of
gunfire in 1932 despite there being
nobody inside the scp-186 site a number
of years later a pair of foundation
agents disappeared on a routine patrol
of the area and were never seen again of
course 23 years after the end of the war
to end all wars the world was plunged
into chaos and found itself at War once
again during this time SCP Foundation
Personnel were instructed to evacuate
the site of scp-186 based on
intelligence from their Allied
operatives who were working undercover
inside the Third Reich as the foundation
disembarked their observation posts a
fanclow was visible coming from SCP
p186 four years passed and the second
world war came to a close the foundation
returned to re-establish their
containment of scp-186 and immediately
discovered 13 corpses dressed in German
army uniforms bearing the Insignia of
the fourth Panzer Army there were a
further 27 bodies of soldiers wearing
the Garb of the Soviet 22nd Army both
sets of bodies had already begun
decaying although someone had removed
the dog tags and anything else that
could identify these dead troops it
seems that history had to some extent
repeated itself as the Nazi and Soviet
forces had clashed on the same
Battlefield where their German and
Russian predecessors had fought during
the Battle of Houston Woods years later
in 1959 a large sinkhole formed in the
Northeast portion of scp-186 four men
were found wandering nearby all
extremely disoriented wearing
decomposing military military uniforms
where they lost survivors of the Nazi
Soviet battle no these men were in World
War One uniforms German Empire and
Russian standard issue they had survived
the battle of Houston woods and Were
Somehow Still Standing even though they
should have died during the first world
war how did these troops manage this
well the final anomalous weapon
recovered at the site of scp-186 were
mortar shells but unsurprisingly these
weren't your standard high explosive
artillery much like those grenades
mentioned earlier these mortar shells
contained a unique previously unseen gas
but instead of causing the Perpetual
pain of being on fire this gas altered
the biology of animal cells that it came
into contact with somehow it triggered a
change that prevented a body's cells
from ceasing life function keeping them
continuously operational in other words
it meant that any soldiers exposed to
this gas simply could not not die that's
right some of the troops involved in the
Battle of Houston Woods are still alive
to this day the SCP Foundation
immediately began Excavating the
sinkhole and discovered 23 bodies buried
beneath in a mass grave there were more
of the surviving World War One soldiers
kept alive for decades by the mortar gas
some of them still had infected wounds
and Battlefield injuries that should
have killed them yet their bodies
refused to Die the soldiers were rounded
up and hauled off to site-23 where the
foundation researchers began assessing
them however they were unable to glean
any useful information from the German
and Russian troops that had been
Unearthed all of the soldiers exhibited
symptoms of extensive psychological
trauma and had developed various mental
disorders while buried alive under the
battlefield they had all been driven to
Insanity perhaps as a result of their
unnaturally extended lifespans maybe
from being buried underground I'm able
to die for so long or perhaps it was the
wartime atrocities they witnessed that
drove the soldiers over the brink
history is a great teacher but those
willing to forget its mistakes are often
doomed to repeat them Matthias nemes and
Dr Jean Duran created the anomalous
weapons responsible for
scp-186 and similar minds would later go
on to build the atomic bomb and
countless weapons of mass destruction
after World Wars The Suffering of
countless troops and civilians these
parts of history mean nothing if we
don't allow ourselves to learn from them
and maybe that's our curse as a species
that we are doomed to fight the war to
end all wars again and again and again
welcome back to SCP explained World War
II is one of the most tragic periods of
recent history and perhaps the defining
event of the 20th century and Not only
was this conflict a horrifying atrocity
that led to the deaths of 75 million
soldiers and civilians it was also a
time of immense weirdness the American
Military created the ghost Army a
tactical deception unit that used
tactics as crazy as inflatable tanks and
wooden airfields to distract and confuse
the Axis powers they also temporarily
renamed hamburgers Liberty stakes in
some places in order to avoid the German
connotations of the original name the
Polish military even gave an actual bear
the rank of Corporal and this bear named
Corporal vojtek became a decorated
military hero but enough about
scp-5464 we've got bigger fish or well
Bears to fry one party in this war had
more than their fair share of alleged
World War II weirdness the Germans Nazi
scientists were performing horrifying
and nonsensical experiments from medical
experiments on prisoners to to attempt
to create large and ridiculous weapons
known as wunderwaffe one of Hitler's
right-hand men Heinrich Himmler took up
residence in a castle where he and his
men allegedly performed odd occult
rituals and even the lebensborn a
deranged Eugenics experiment intended to
produce a huge stalk of Aryan children
from SS member fathers and if all that
seems certifiably insane which for the
record it is then the stuff the SCP
Foundation has been suppressing will
make your toes curl we've already
covered the fact that even Hitler
himself copied by Stalin with the help
of sarkic wizards is now classified as
scp-2430 and held in containment by the
foundation but really that's just the
tip of the iceberg we can thank a shady
group known as the obscura core for the
creation or utilization of a lot of
these artifacts and entities as we
discussed in our video on the immortal
Hitler clone the obscuracore was Nazi
Germany's answer to the SCP Foundation
though their highly unethical methods
were much more like a racist version of
the chaos Insurgency this group of loyal
occult thugs was charged with hunting
down any anomalous artifacts that would
give Germany The Edge it needed in the
war effort think the kind of guys going
after the Ark of the Covenant and the
Holy Grail while trying to kill Indiana
Jones of course seeing as Germany still
lost the war in the end they weren't
exactly the best at their job but that
doesn't mean they don't have a long list
of bizarre and often dangerous anomalies
to their name starting with
scp-2367 this is a device so Infamous
that not even the SCP Foundation has
been able to fully suppress knowledge of
its existence popularly known as diglaka
meaning the bell in German this device
has been a popular staple among time
travel and alien conspiracy theorists
and those theorists honestly aren't that
far from the truth the Bell is a spatial
and temporal Transportation device
created by the Germans during World War
II in hopes of of teleporting spies
soldiers and Equipment Behind Enemy
Lines and terrifyingly the Machine
actually worked and was able to
transport multiple SS officers however
there is one detail that makes digglaka
a little less terrifying everything they
transport materializes several hundred
feet over the top of their intended
destinations in the case of all
transported SS officers this means that
they appeared high in the air and
immediately fell to their Doom like
Wiley E coyote SS officers hitting the
ground at incredibly high speeds is
always a delightful mental image as
funny and incompetent as this is there
is actually one major threat posed by a
cp2367 the SCP Foundation rated a number
of obscura strongholds during World War
II as a part of an operation called
operation Hammer during one of their
raids a large group of around 1400
German soldiers along with a huge number
of large vehicles and pieces of military
equipment fled via the Glock they all
disappeared through the teleporter and
according to all Foundation estimates
they're likely to manifest again in 2031
they'll rain down from the sky near
Berlin crushing everything below under
the weight of their own vehicles and
bodies a mobile task force nicknamed
himmler's housekeepers has been
mobilized to clear the area and reduce
all possible civilian fatalities when
this happens German engineering at its
finest right but hey let's give those
mad Nazi inventors another chance to
prove themselves with the second even
bigger one Dev offer designed by Albert
Speer German minister of armaments and
war production under Adolf Hitler its
scp-044 the biggest artillery weapon
ever created it's a ginormous Cannon 251
000 kilograms or 251 metric tons in
weight and so huge that it required two
Freight locomotives at the same time to
transport it the Nazis were big fans of
absurdly huge weapons whether they were
cannons giant plane or the world's
heaviest tanks almost as though they
were compensating for something but
there is one thing that makes zero four
four special to the point of being
anomalous it can fire literally anything
when something is placed inside the
firing chamber of scp-044 the weapon
will transform into a powerful explosive
payload with its explosive power being
proportional to the size of the objects
placed inside even crowds of people
could be transformed into deadly
explosive rounds one of the largest
objects that the foundation fired off
was the administrator's diesel pickup
truck weighing 8 900 kilograms how on
Earth did the Nazis ever lose with a
weapon like this on their side right
well much like so many of their other
weapons it was a victim of their own
greed weapons this big just couldn't be
moved practically and were easily routed
by less powerful but more maneuverable
Allied weapons next we have another
anomalous Nazi failure though this one
was intended to give life rather than
take it for once the anomaly in question
is
scp-2936 a secret Nazi military and
research base hidden in the cold reaches
of Antarctica the place has likely been
abandoned by humans since the 1950s but
there is one entity that still rolls
through the Halls on rumbling
caterpillar tracks an advanced sentient
robot nicknamed the stalmudder or steel
mother powered by a mysterious power
source shaped like an ambiguous glowing
symbol on its chest who would have
guessed that the Nazi design sensibility
was tacky the stalmudder is there to
maintain the glasgowbarmotran or glass
wombs where a number of desiccated human
fetuses are held the intention of this
base was clear much like the lebensborn
project we mentioned at the start of the
video this was a controlled breeding
program supported by the Nazis deranged
philosophy of eugenics but after the war
when the Nazis attending the base
presumably fled for their lives there
was some kind of accident that destroyed
the Seal of the glass wombs allowing the
amniotic fluid to leak out and killing
the fetuses inside but due to a
malfunction the stalmudder's Diagnostics
were way off and they never realized
that its mission was futile when
researchers attempted to inform the
machine of that fact it simply replied
they are moving like the dead soldiers
are not soldiers
and mechanical parameters
good Kingdom will grow strong and brave
and wise this is
the next anomaly wasn't created by the
Germans or the obscura but it was you
utilized by them it's
scp-3457 a collection of strange rituals
artifacts and workings known as the
rites of Solomon if the correct
artifacts are collected and the rights
are performed the executors of the
ritual have the ability to control the
distribution of magic or thalmaturgy
across the globe its obscura's plan to
perform the right and remove the ability
to perform thalmaturgy from anyone who
wasn't of Germanic descent giving them
German magic Supremacy this was the end
of the infamous seventh occult War which
was the major geopolitical event that
led to the formation of the global
occult Coalition coinciding roughly with
what we civilians consider World War II
luckily through a collaboration between
the SCP Foundation and the precursor to
the global occult Coalition the Allied
occult Coalition obscura was defeated
before they could complete the ritual
and Grant magical Supremacy for the
Fatherland since the defeat of obscura
in this pivotal battle organizations
like the SCP Foundation the GOC and
others have sworn to keep the different
artifacts necessary to perform the
rights of Solomon's safe and secure some
are kept in public museums as part of a
global sting operation to catch
remaining members of obscura who hope to
someday attempt the dark ritual again
some of the items remain in the hands of
scattered obscura remnants to this day
okay so Arcane historical rights are a
little complicated let's hop back to
another wacky Wonder Waffa to cleanse
our palate something like
scp-3721 remember when we said the
Germans were kind of obsessed with
having the biggest goddess guns back
during World War II they were also
apparently ahead of their time in this
regard as in 1943 they were able to
construct a fully operational orbital
Cannon and an Earthbound computer bank
that allowed them to operate its strikes
remotely but even scarier than a giant
orbital Cannon controlled by the Nazis
is a giant orbital cannon that's
completely out of control that's right
the computer on the ground is autonomous
and decides the best time to make its
strikes by monitoring news broadcasts of
current events so if you feel like a day
full of bad news is unpleasant just be
grateful that it wasn't the day that
activated the massive death satellite
looming up above maybe the idea of land
being bombarded by an orbital Cannon
freaks you out a little understandable
really maybe you'd prefer to flee to the
water for safety but you're not safe
from the Germans there either and we're
not talking about them stealing your
beach chairs while you're going for a
swim we're talking about
scp-4217 which was once known as the
Bismarck which was a German World War II
battleship before it was appropriated by
a giant cephalopod that not only has
giant dangerous tentacles but also has
the ability to use all of the ship's
weapons against you too huh what will
you think of next Germany and finally
per perhaps the strangest obscure Wonder
waffer of all a dangerous semantic
weapon known as
scp-3878 it's a deadly word-based
infectious Cognito Hazard created in a
single patient zero via a strict regimen
of psychotropic drugs electroconvulsive
therapy and at the conclusion of the
program treponation to create an
extremely strong anti-concept within the
subject's mind when this person is
activated with a trigger stimuli this
will begin to spread the Cognito Hazard
causing a lethal effect to anyone who
doesn't speak the subject's native
language fluently the first infecti
would have been German if the plan came
to fruition so all but fluent German
speakers would have been killed by the
infection it's a solid plan by which we
mean a metal gear solid plan
incidentally killing the victims of this
Cognito Hazard was never actually the
plan they just hoped to erase other
languages though given that the Nazis
weren't exactly people of high moral
fiber be willing to bet that they were
probably A-Okay with killing anyone who
wasn't a fluent speaker of German anyway
and there you have it a tasterplate of
the wackiest wonderwaffe and the
Sinister soldiers and scientists who
made them a reality or at least tried to
twist them to their own gain it's
honestly lucky for all of us that the
Nazis during World War II were a gang of
arrogant and incompetent buffoons
because if that weren't the case we'd
probably be speaking German right now
though if you'd like to live on the
bright side at least we'd be safe from
scp-3878 when you think of the SCP
Foundation you probably think of the
organization being primarily based in
the United States after all many of the
anomalies we cover here on SCP explained
happen to take place in America so it's
easy to lose sight of the bigger picture
the fact of the matter is that the
anomalous is not just confined to the
United States and if it were the
foundation would have a much easier time
doing its job than it actually does
unfortunately for the Foundation it's
not just the us that they have to focus
their efforts on it's the entire world
that's right no matter where you are on
earth no matter how far you travel the
threat of being the victim of an
unsuspecting anomalous incident Remains
the Same even on your family vacation to
Disney World of course the foundation's
mission is massively expansive too with
each object requiring not only
significant resources to capture but
even more to effectively contain and
study over a long period of time and
then you have the utilities of each site
keeping the power on and the water
running or what about actually paying
the hard-working SCP Personnel who put
their lives on the line every day how
about keeping Global reconnaissance as a
watchful eye in case of talk of any
unnatural incident start making the
rounds in the Ordinary World what about
maintaining a standing army of trained
task force operatives far deadlier than
any other military force on the planet
resources to cover up events as soon as
they happen field agents database
expenses it's unimaginable to think of
the costs of operating the foundation in
one country let alone on a global scale
so how do they manage this heavy
responsibility how does the SCP
Foundation divide up its resources
accordingly as well as raise enough
money to continue operating think about
it if you were an organization having to
cover the entire globe in service of
protecting Humanity from the anomalous
what would be the best way of managing
your resources first you need to make
sure you are backed by the richest of
the rich who could use some of their
personal wealth to fund your goals well
that's the overseer Council the group at
the top of the foundation composed of
some of the most affluent and Wealthy
individuals in the world second you'd
make sure you had a means of generating
Revenue the foundation can't exactly
open itself for donations from the
public and it can't issue taxes but it
can have others do that for them cover
several businesses in sourcing funding
from the governments of the world either
legitimately or through blackmailing are
two Surefire ways to keep the cash
flowing endlessly who knows how many
Fortune 500 companies are actually owned
by the foundation there's a lot of money
in the world to go around but someone
needs to capitalize on it in order to
get it but the most important way to
manage global resources is
decentralization remember what we said
about the perception of the foundation
being us-based well it is true that the
foundation has its origins in the United
States and the country is the center of
a large number of containment efforts
but the English-speaking branch of the
foundation is far from the only one
allow us to introduce International
branches or Dash int for short the
foundation likes to codify its various
branches based on the majority language
spoken there so the English-speaking
Branch would cover Nations such as the
United States Canada and parts of Europe
while in regions where Chinese is spoken
the Chinese branch presides over the
territory truly the containment of the
anomalous is a global effort with at
least one Foundation site located in
each country Africa India Japan Latin
America there isn't a part of the world
that the foundation doesn't have covered
and for good reason too anomalous
objects can be discovered anywhere and
everywhere having locations near all
major population centers isn't just a
luxury of having unlimited funding it is
the very thing that necessitates such
funding and with International branches
adhering to their own policies holding
their own personnel and speaking their
own languages it should come as no
surprise that they have their own
database of SCP objects too that's right
each branch has an archive of files of
their own written based on objects
contained in their respective country
imagine being the guy who's just
finishing reading all the files
currently existing in the English
database when you realize is then you
have to Drudge through several more
databases filled with thousands upon
thousands of files just to be the
completionist your heart wants you to be
it is a time consuming task but that's
what we're here for and today we're
going to boost your own International
database with coverage of
scp-007-int an anomaly sourced from the
foundation's global database it all
started in masarosa Italy a medium-sized
Town located just outside Pisa it's not
famous for much well outside of hosting
the annual masarosa International piano
competition which we should remind you
that we're all very excited about this
year considering Dr clef himself has
decided he'd enter but enough about
agent ukulele's wild piano skills let's
get back to the story at hand a
contingent of mobile task force
operatives sourced from a squad dubbed
smoking anomalous snakes who belong to
the foundation's Italian Branch were
stationed in the town for the past week
given that masarosa is smaller than the
average city with a population number
during just over twenty two thousand
these operatives had to take extra
precaution as to not give away their
presence in a town where everyone knows
everyone a gaggle of unfamiliar faces
making their way through could set off
proverbial alarms in the local
population the foundation operatives
were there for a single purpose to
Source the production of anomalous
Weaponry rumored to be occurring
throughout the region now why is this a
problem in the first place as technology
advances War changes along with it
sometimes necessitating the need for
more efficient weapons and inspiring
their development Spears to deal with
the invading tribes on land horses and
chariots to rush those with Spears bows
and arrows to combat horses War has
always made use of new technology to
make combat more efficient and deadly an
anomalous Weaponry is no different after
all not every paranormal organization
holds the same ethos as the foundation's
secure contain protect mentality there
are many groups of interest such as the
dreaded chaos Insurgency or the
foundation's greatest rival the global
occult Coalition that would be more than
happy to utilize Research into the
anomalous for military purposes and who
can blame them with anomalous Weaponry
situations can be resolved and enemies
eradicated easier and deadlier than ever
before up against a world that doesn't
abide by their mission even the
foundation is forced to utilize
anomalous Weaponry albeit on a much
smaller scale take task force Alpha 9
lass hope a squad made up entirely of
SCP objects such as scp-105 Iris
Thompson and scp-4494 the world's
greatest Arbiter of vigilante justice
otherwise known as the Specter even
mobile task forces such as samsara a
group of heavily augmented cybernetic
super soldiers make use of anomalous
Weaponry to further Advance their
efficiency on the field after all task
forces spend their time combating
anomalies in the field it only makes
sense to to Fight Fire with Fire so to
speak third party Sellers and producers
of anomalous Weaponry often provide the
technology to establish groups of
Interest so the foundation getting the
jump on a distribution center in
masarosa Italy was a strategic move on
the part of the foundation they weren't
sure of the exact details but their
sources tipped them off about a gang of
fascists neo-nazis in the area working
on supplying anomalous Weaponry to the
criminal underworld it's bad enough that
the trigger-happy radicals at the chaos
Insurgency have access to anomalous
means of Destruction imagine if every
two-bit gangster and minor criminal had
their hands on something as deadly as an
SCP object and they could acquire even
more powerful equipment if they wanted
if the fascists made their money who
knows where their anomalous Weaponry
would wind up the foundation wasn't sure
what they were manufacturing but they
were positive that it wasn't good their
Source explicitly described it as a
weapon that could change the course of
War as they understood it a living
breathing Shield naturally the
foundation was just as interested in
potentially finding a purpose for this
mystery weapon as they were in taking it
out of the hands of the black market
suppliers what uses could it hold in the
field could it provide an extra layer of
protection for the foundation operatives
the operatives were compiled from a
Vanguard and reconnaissance team and
were the only ones the resource strained
Italian Branch had available for the job
they spent days combing through the town
until they stumbled upon what they
believed to be a hideout for the gang
while attempting to investigate a
mysterious man ran out in front of the
team darting towards them from across
the street the team went to shoot but
hesitated after realizing that the man
was accompanied by a mysterious silver
balloon-like entity ominously floating
above his shoulder not only that but he
was wearing a full suit of protective
equipment almost like a beekeeper's suit
the operatives opened fire at the
unidentified Target but before their
bullets could make contact the silver
balloon began bubbling and spread itself
across the man's body like a protective
sheet it was then they knew they found
their living Shield the bullet slid
right off the man hitting the liquid
covering him and immediately being
negated by its anomalous properties then
before the team could react the liquid
shot forward detaching from the man's
body and latching onto a foundation
operative the silver gel began to writhe
and constrict attempting to absorb the
operative through his protective gear in
a quick executive decision the team lead
made the choice to put the operative who
was in the midst of being absorbed by
the gel out of his misery after all they
couldn't take risks when dealing with an
unknown anomaly especially one that they
already knew was being utilized as a
deadly weapon as soon as the body
dropped dead both the liquid and the
gang member took off through the streets
and the foundation gave Pursuit the
foundation chased the man through the
narrow maze-like streets of the town
with the silver liquid tailing after
them and attempting to absorb even more
operatives thankfully the gel wasn't
fast the man however was another story
The operatives chased and chased
indiscriminately unloading a salvo of
bullets into the general area a few
struck puncturing the man's skin and
causing him to bleed following the trail
of blood the foundation was able to
Corner him into a street alley but then
all of a sudden the gel burst through
the concrete wall the man was backed up
against the anomaly now larger than ever
the goo reconnected with the man
shielding him from the foundation's
Firepower and allowing him to run away
and escape the foundation briefly
retreated and reconvened with their
superiors to try to find the best
strategy to move forward they then took
to the streets again searching for the
man and any trace of the anomaly they
found bits of the liquid strewn through
the streets squirming and writhing
unlike the first batch these bits were
able to be neutralized via regular
bullets their search eventually bore
fruit and they found the a man patching
himself up in a nearby Cellar he had a
briefcase and the area around him seemed
to be a type of laboratory still they
were unable to find the silver balloon
anomaly the operatives with weapons
drawn attempted to speak with the man
but he lashed out and shot at them
prompting them to shoot back immediately
killing him they weren't able to get
much information from him but it was an
act of self-defense the foundation now
with their only source of information
gone resorted to looking through the
rest of the basement they found a series
of documents held inside the room all
written in Italian they also found a
tunnel leading outside the town and a
small cart that was intended to be used
to transport cylinders containing the
silver liquid out of masarosa the
foundation was very quick to stop this
anomaly from getting out on the black
market as it seemed like this was a
distribution and testing center but with
the man dead and the gel contained they
realized their mission was complete and
collected all remaining documents and
traces of the silver liquid anomaly in a
joint effort between the Italian and
lucifon branches the liquid was
transported to Brazil for further
research and classified as
scp-007-int the lucifon branches Board
of superintendents had made the decision
earlier that
scp-007-int held historical and research
significance for the two branches as
some of the task force members that
aided in the capture of the anomaly were
sourced from Brazil the documents were
shared between both branches and
chemical research on the object was
conducted immediately the foundation
discovered the reason why the liquid
responded so quickly to the man who was
Distributing it and why it works
perfectly as a living Shield
scp-007-int is sentient and capable of
recognizing patterns and portraying
emotion albeit two small degrees
Research into
scp-007-int's composition and responses
to stimuli in a lab environment
continued one researcher from the
Italian Branch noted that this wasn't
the first time they had encountered an
anomaly like this when dealing with a
group of organizations known as the
fascist Council of the occult the
foundation discovered a heavily redacted
and secret anomalous weapon with certain
properties similar to
scp-007-int while the details of this
weapon were lost to the database and
above our clearance level we can assume
that due to the Nazi connection between
the man Distributing the liquid and the
fascist Council of the occult that
portions of
scp-007-int managed to make their way to
the black market and proliferate the
criminal underworld but when all the
research was said and done what was
scp-007-int the studies were conducted
as a joint operation between the two
branches and as a result allowed for a
significant amount of testing
researchers found that the gel was
adaptable durable and intelligent to a
certain degree but they also discovered
that their data was incredibly similar
to another anomaly in their database
recorded by the lucifon branches
processor the scientific Academy of the
anomalous you see the foundation hasn't
been around forever before at the
anomalous containment world was
decentralized and composed of tinier
organizations and this was one of them
as it turns out this organization
recorded data remarkably similar to
scp-007-int but the details of the
research was lost due to an incident
involving Rogue Agents defecting from
the organization think the chaos
Insurgency but before them too the two
instances of the anomaly were apparently
a perfect match to
scp-007-int and the two branches had
both contained the same anomaly across
decades without being aware that the
other had done it well the documents
were lost when defecting agents broke
away from the academy researchers
theorized that they either defected into
or sold information about the anomaly to
the fascist Council who were able to
improve the liquid and turn it into a
formidable military-grade weapon still
the experiments with
scp-007-int proved to be a success the
anomaly sapience allowed it to form a
bond with its host protecting and
showing the desire to comfort them if
need be what a nice little hunk of
deadly Gunk right but then just as the
branches were about to give up on
finding the Academy's old documentation
for
scp-007-int they happened to discover it
the anomaly was given the code name
project Mel this initial research found
that the anomaly was incredibly adaptive
as seen below instance Alpha is the most
belligerent case of
scp-007-int it prefers being involved in
combat-oriented exercises and watching
martial performances Alpha has
demonstrated a certain degree of
infatuation to the party with in its
conception the best performance by using
its pseudopods in attempts to imitate
some executed movements for the
respective party to see instance beta is
an exemplary case of person anality I've
witnessed beta abducting a stuffed
penguin irresponsibly given by one of
its operators to demonstrate affection
beta also displayed excitement when
presented with pictures of penguins an
extraordinary situation involving beta
happened when it parted itself its copy
assumed the form of a penguin which beta
proceeded to care for in the likeness of
an animal companion beta protected and
guided the copy through the training
course until the spontaneous exploration
thereof instance gamma possesses a
particularly High physical intelligence
it is expressly competent in solving
movement-related problematics such as
obstacle courses involving the
manipulation of sensitive objects and
complex movement and transformation
patterns interestingly gamma has been
seen reacting to music by dancing to the
respective Rhythm this original
documentation proved to be valuable to
the foundation as it provided further
information on what occurred when
scp-007-int was stolen from its original
original location and placed into the
hands of the fascist Council on December
25th 1972 several security breaches
across the academy occurred as sleeper
agents of the council stole various
anomalous assets from storehouses and
vaults across the country for two hours
the group of six Rogue individuals took
what they could smuggling the objects
away from the organization for the
purposes of using and selling them to
the highest bidder objects stolen
included project Mel several prototype
Prosthetics and various other pieces of
high Security Academy documentation the
foundation also discovered that these
sleeper agents within the academy were
students researchers and operatives who
had been working with the organization
for years sometimes decades given their
history it's possible that they may have
been coerced rather than them being
outright agents of the fascist Council
of the occult unfortunately all of them
expired during the interrogation
procedures and only one survived
captured by the academy via suspended
the animation though their whereabouts
in the present day are unknown it's
unknown if the foundation has seen the
last of
scp-007-int or if samples of the deadly
adaptive Shield are still lurking in the
anomalous criminal underworld regardless
whoever possesses
scp-007-int is surely to be a formidable
Force for anyone to go up against the
booming steps echoed through the museum
corridors pharaohs Emperors and
Mongolian War leaders all stood stock
still as the terrified security guard
ran between them Roger Pascal swung his
flashlight this way and that the light
glinted on the polished steel of ancient
Weaponry muskets scimitars and cannons
exhibit after exhibit flashed past him
as he ran through the dark Museum there
was no way it was real no possible way
he was having a bad dream that's all it
was a bad dream the shaking ground under
his feet and the marching Rhythm of the
impossibly heavy footsteps behind him
told him that it was real all right it
had just been a normal shift like any
other just a regular Night at the Museum
Roger had been sipping his coffee and
listening to the radio when all of a
sudden he felt his chair start rumbling
beneath him he put his coffee down on
the table and washed as it recoiled as
the footsteps grew louder and closer he
got up to investigate and couldn't
believe what he'd walked in on skidding
around the corner he tumbled into a
medieval suit of armor and scented
crashing across the floor chainmail
helmet gauntlets all of it rattled and
crashed to the marble floor echoing all
through the museum then there was a
sudden deathly silence as the footsteps
stopped Roger didn't breathe then they
started again heading straight towards
him it was all Roger could do to lie on
his back in front of the giant Taxi
Derby eagle and point his flashlight at
the door as the Monstrous figure of the
stone Soldier walked around the corner
musket in hand Woodstock Vermont
1995. it was a normal day just like any
other the birds were singing in the
trees and there was a gentle breeze
blowing through nothing at all out of
the ordinary except of course the statue
that opened its eyes the Civil War
Memorial had been a staple of Woodstock
for well over 100 Years A plinth sitting
in the middle of a park with a young
Soldier on top of it holding a musket
peacefully by his side the statue had
watched over the town generation after
generation except now its watching had
become a little more active it took
several hours for anyone to notice dog
walkers went past listening to their
walkmans a banker sat on a bench
opposite deep in conversation on a giant
brick phone it was only when a young
child running after her football looked
up at the Statue and saw it looking back
at her that things changed the girl's
parents didn't listen to her of course
parents rarely do but word quickly went
around the girls school most of the time
the statue was totally still no movement
in the eyes at all but on occasion would
a group of kids gathered around it and
talked to it enough the statue seemed to
look down at them as if it was listening
but that was it no grown-ups were
particularly interested in what the
children were saying and even a lot of
the children who saw it went home
concluding that they must have been
imagining things so six months went by
without anyone really paying the statue
much attention that was until it fired
its gun in a quiet rural Town everyone
hears a gunshot but for a long time no
one could work out where it had come
from police gathered around the park
searching all around where the weapon
had been heard the only clue they could
find was a small hole in the wall of a
shop across across the street a couple
of officers joked that the shot must
have come from the statue itself
everyone laughed it off except for a
couple of the school kids who were
playing nearby less than two weeks later
another shot rang out in the middle of
the night and a group of confused police
officers rushed to the park to
investigate what had happened the only
thing they found was a dead bird lying
on the sidewalk shot to death again the
jokes went around the department that it
must have been the statue who did it
except this time the officers were all
laughing a little less enthusiastically
without much crime going on in Woodstock
Vermont the department decided to take
the shooting quite seriously going so
far as to perform an autopsy on the dead
pigeon but when they cut the animal open
and looked at the wound inside its chest
they were filled with even more
confusion than they were before it
wasn't a conventional bullet lodged into
the bird's rib cage at all it was
perfectly round and made of what
appeared to be own but the next shot
that rang out from the Memorial Park was
unmistakable it was a weekend in the
middle of the summer vacation so the
park was full of families all sitting
around having picnics barbecues and
staring up at the sky watching the birds
Circle lazily overhead bang one of the
pigeons exploded in a burst of feathers
and plummeted out of the sky landing on
the sidewalk in front of the whole town
in shock all the town's folk turned
around to see the stone statue down on
one knee with his musket on his shoulder
the statue looked down at all of them
surprised at the attention then quickly
got back to its feet and resumed its
normal stance reports flooded all the
local papers and news stations the event
was blamed on mass hysteria a kind of
group hallucination where everyone was
somehow sharing the same story but the
number of people coming forward with the
exact same account was irrefutable
evidence that's where the foundation had
to step in in January during 1996
containment procedures began and the
statue was given the designation
scp-011 of course a large contingent of
Agents suddenly appearing in a small
town would raise a lot of Suspicion so
the foundation had to move very
cautiously One agent at a time the
foundation established itself in
Woodstock and began to study the statue
day in and day out by sitting on park
benches even looking through cut out
holes in newspapers and wearing fake
outfits so as not to arouse suspicion
steadily over time the statue appeared
to gain either a heightened Mobility or
just a renewed sense of confidence while
much of the time it did remain standing
immobile it would begin to occasionally
stretch when it thought no one was
looking and glanced this way and that in
apparent annoyance with the birds
circling over its head the shooting
steadily grew more regular Foundation
agents observed several birds being
picked out of the sky by the musket fire
of scp-011 over the following week a
clear pattern started to emerge the
statue would only fire at birds that
seemed to be flying above it or getting
too curious about it in fact the more
fecal matter built up on the Statue the
more aggressive it would be both in its
body language and mood seemed to sour
the dirtier it got while there were
initial concerns about the SCP
potentially turning its rifle towards
the local townspeople these worries were
largely dismissed as scp-011 gradually
started to build up a rapport with those
around it before long the caretakers of
the park were having exchanges with the
SCP these exchanges started with the
caretaker speaking directly to the SCP
and at nodding or subtly acknowledging
the things they said but over time the
interactions grew more and more
personable in the year 2000
scp-011 spoke for the first time it had
just fired its rifle picking off a
pigeon from over 200 feet away when a
caretaker mildly exclaimed nah shot the
statue out dipped his head to the
caretaker and said Thank you in a
gravelly voice this marked a significant
change in the foundation's approach to
the containment of scp-011 up until this
point the SCP was considered a broadly
harmless member of the local town
community however its ability to speak
raised concerns as to this scp's
development four years ago it had been
an immobile statue with nothing out of
the ordinary to raise any suspicions
among those around it where would its
cognitive development end now that it
had gained the ability to talk
groundskeepers and agents posing as
groundskeepers struck up conversations
with scp-011 as often as possible at
first these exchanges were brief but
over time the SCP became steadily more
vocal until soon it was engaged in
intellectual debates and sharing its
views on the world with anyone who would
listen it was becoming clear that new
containment measures were needed in fact
scp-011 soon lost interest in shooting
birds or rather the SCP was persuaded to
stop shooting birds while the prospect
of having animals defecate on it still
appeared to anger the statue the
foundation was able to explain through
ideological grounds why shooting birds
was a disproportionate response relative
to the minor harm they were doing to it
King to engage in philosophical and
ethical discussions the statue was very
open to hearing the foundation's
viewpoint on the issue and having
sufficiently considered all sides of the
debate decided that it would in fact be
better for the well-being of all
involved if it stopped shooting the
birds from the sky in return the
caretakers and Foundation agents
promised to do their best to clean it
regularly and keep the animals at Bay
but with word of this bizarre tourist
attraction steadily Gathering momentum
as the age of email began to take off
the foundation decided that it would be
best to relocate scp-011 entirely
however agents who had been living in
Woodstock for the prior four years were
hesitant to relocate The Entity to a
test chamber or storage facility the
benefits that it had brought to the
local community far outweighed the risks
and threats that it posed the statue had
become a local celebrity smiling and
waving at children who went past and
even offering brief history lessons to
any confused tourists who found
themselves wandering through the park
most just assumed it was a person in
gray paint it was agent Khan who came up
with the idea of relocating scp-011 to a
museum being kept indoors away from the
dangers of any fecal bombing runs was
the main priority Khan argued that
within a museum the statue would blend
in seamlessly with the exhibits around
it furthermore if anyone did see the
statue move or talk they would assume
that it was an interactive exhibit and
treated as such having shown a real love
for Academia history and debate Khan
believed that scp-011 would benefit
greatly from being in such a setting
both learning and eventually even
teaching about the history of the
American Civil War however when all
these arguments were put forward to the
Statue itself it was hesitant having
spent the entirety of its cognitive
existence standing on the same plinth
shooting at the same pigeons the idea of
relocating to somewhere new and unknown
was very intimidating even with the
Soldier's mindset
scp-011 was still feeling incredibly
nervous about the idea of moving house
agent Khan and scp-011 found themselves
locked in a stalemate try a she might
convincing the SCP to leave its current
home was like talking to a brick wall or
rather a Stonewall the pair of them
ended up dropping the conversation for a
couple years focused instead on
psychiatric evaluations and history
lessons for the SCP in 2002 the
foundation officially declared that
scp-011 had achieved sentience with a
great enough level of self-awareness to
pass as a normal human being aside from
the fact that it was composed entirely
of stone for two years agent Khan talked
to scp-011 every day on the Park Bench
the slats on the bench had to be
replaced several times as the weight of
the statue broke through them snapping
them clean in half on several occasions
during this period the pair of them
built up a rapport rarely seen between
humans and scps so much so that in 2004
agent Khan managed to convince scp-011
to move to a local Museum on one
condition she would go as well the
foundation agreed to the terms deciding
that Khan could take on the role of
being a researcher in the museum that
way she could keep an eye on scp-011 and
Report any activities while the
foundation officially relinquished
control over the SCP what happened next
was perhaps rather predictable or at
least it would be predictable to anyone
who had worked with agent Khan and
scp-011 during that time in Vermont as
the pair of them moved into their new
lives at the Museum romantic feelings
blossomed between them seeing as scp-011
is officially outside of the SCP
foundation's jurisdiction there has been
no official inquiry into the nature and
practicalities of the relationship
between the woman and the statue but
from the reports that make their way to
the foundation every three months it is
clear that both are very much enjoying
the privacy of their new Arrangement
Roger Pascal closed his eyes Imagining
the barrel racing higher and higher
until it was pointed squarely at his
face he had been told by his bosses not
to ask questions about the origins of
the statue that had suddenly appeared in
the Civil War section even when he saw
the statue's eyes moving he'd kept his
mouth shut that was until he was doing
his security rounds that night and heard
those booming footsteps leading him
behind one of the displays he had rushed
over in a panic peering around the
corner he had been shocked to see Miss
Khan one of the researchers here and the
Civil War statue engaged in a passionate
kiss he had turned and bolted as fast as
he could until he ended up here
terrified on the floor as he imagined
the musket being leveled at him but then
a second pair of footsteps joined the
group and a woman's laugh filled the
room opening his eyes the security guard
saw the pair of them the statue and the
researcher standing in the doorway
laughing about the whole situation the
musket was slung over the man's shoulder
as he offered a cold Stony hand down to
the security guard to help him up
ironically there was something about the
statue's smile that softened Roger's
Stony heart as he was hauled to his feet
I have so many questions agent Lane's
eyes scanned over the document he'd been
sent the decryption program had finished
unraveling the sensitive data that the
SCP Foundation cyber security kept
hidden beneath layers of encryption it
had been a few hours since he'd received
the leaked document sent to him from a
mole that had been active within the
ranks of foundation Personnel for some
time and as for what was on this secret
document it was an intake list the
records and names of everyone recently
brought into d-class Lane scoured the
rose upon rows of inmates violent
criminals the worst of the worst that
the foundation used as human Lab Rats
then his eyes settled over one name the
exact one he'd been looking for the true
identity of a man codenamed the hatchet
a mass murderer responsible for
coordinating multiple acts of
international terrorism but to agent
Lane this man wasn't a threat to be
feared he was a bait in a trap for
something far worse the global occult
Coalition had long been the face of
officially sanctioned legitimacy in the
fight against the anomalous while the
SCP Foundation operated in a more
clandestine fashion the GOC was operated
by and acted under the authority of the
United Nations they were mandated with
policing the Paranormal World a role no
somebody in the GOC took lightly their
ultimate goal was a world rid of all
anomalies while the foundation opted for
containment the Coalition preferred
extermination but despite this
fundamental difference in their
operational structures the two
organizations maintained a fragile
Alliance which is why Agent Lane needed
bait in order for his plan to work the
objective was simple kill
scp-096 also known as the shy guy an
anomalous entity with a long
disproportionate human body that could
use impossible speeds to kill anyone
that looked at its face even through an
image that was what worried the GOC it
seemed all too easy for scp-096 to be
used as a weapon especially for
assassinations it wouldn't take much for
the foundation to mail a photo of
scp-096 to anyone say a politician who
opposed them or the head of another
group of Interest then all they'd have
to do do is sit back and wait as scp-096
dispatched its unwitting Target along
with any witnesses that happened to see
it appear so the Coalition had decided
it was time to take the shy guy off the
board before anyone got any unsavory
ideas but there was still one issue with
that given the GOC and SCP foundation's
rocky relationship agent Lane had been
instructed to leave no trace of the
coalition's involvement he needed
someone else to be responsible for the
actual elimination of scp-096 so that
the GOC could deny any and all
involvement that's when he'd gotten the
idea who better to call on for a covert
strictly off the book's Mission only one
of the world's most elite special forces
units with no affiliation to the GOC
whatsoever Delta Force engineering a
scenario where Lane could get the Deltas
to take out scp-096 was going to be
tricky he couldn't give them a direct
order to kill the creature that could
too easily lead back to the GOC so The
Mastermind behind this Mission needed to
think outside of the box how could he
get the attention of Delta Force well by
offering up one of the World's Most
Wanted terrorists after all Delta Force
was renowned for undertaking missions
that involved counter-terrorism as well
as the securing and sometimes
elimination of high-value targets and
that was where the hatchet came into
plan given the severity and extreme
nature of as many crimes he was
certainly considered high value by the
US government however it was while
awaiting trial that the hatchet had
disappeared under mysterious
circumstances the official story was
that he had died in prison following a
fight with another inmate but rumors
circulated about an escape attempt of
course neither were correct now agent
Lane knew the truth the foundation had
him which means he was within the reach
of the GOC issuing a coded command to
his mole working inside the SCP found
Nation Lane instructed that the hatchet
would be making an escape of sorts at
least that's how it would appear but it
would be completely staged under the
cover of night the mold drugged and
kidnapped the hatchet breaking open an
air vent and making it look like someone
had crawled their way through nobody had
and instead the hatchet was carried
unconscious to a foundation vehicle the
mole had hot wired if he drove off in
his own car the foundation would be able
to trace the Escape back to him and then
the GOC bundling the terrorist into the
trunk the mold drove several miles away
from the foundation's site to an
extraction point where agent Lane was
waiting so here's how you're gonna lure
out the Delta Force the mole said as he
and lame lifted the hatchet aboard the
chopper but how are you going to get
scp-096 to come out too Foundation keeps
it crying in that cell I can't stop it
getting out when someone sees it though
right lane replied yeah it moves way too
fast the mole confirmed all someone has
to do is look at it and it can get out
even when even when they look at a
picture of it the agent finished his
sentence Oh
the mole gasped realization spreading
across his face are from the hatch in
here isn't just bait to lure out Delta
Force agent Lane explained he's bait for
both
scp-096 and Delta will both be coming
after him that way as far as the
foundation knows
scp-096 will be killed during a standard
Delta Force mission to recapture an
on-the-run terrorist Mastermind and
meanwhile the GOC gets complete
deniability was nothing to do with us we
weren't involved perfect scapegoat the
mole commented thing is if this is meant
to be such a covert Mission then why
risk security by telling me dead man
don't talk agent Lane replied quietly
pulling a silenced handgun from his
holster and squeezing the trigger firing
three times for good measure with the
loose end tied up nothing linked the
global cult coalition to the hatchet's
apparent Escape sure enough the
foundation fell for it hook line and
sinker while they were busy locking down
the facility see healing the air vents
that they believe their d-class prisoner
had escaped through agent Lane had the
hatchet handcuffed securely under lock
and key the helicopter took them a short
distance to a quiet airstrip where they
boarded an Uncharted plane to a safe
house to avoid any further links to the
GOC Lane had to transport the hatchet as
Off the Grid as possible until they got
him to their destination even then the
safe house couldn't be one that the GOC
had ever used before any Link in the
foundation or Delta Force would smell a
rat the leaked intelligence that was
soon received by Delta Force seemed to
confirm their worst fears Not only was
the hatchet still alive but it was free
and apparently hiding out in a safe
house while they would never publicly
acknowledge the unit's activities the
Department of Defense issued an
objective to Delta Force Tracked Down
The Hatchet to its current location and
either capture him or kill him a squad
of some of the most highly trained
United States troops were assembled
before joining down Delta Force most of
them had been recruited from the elite
75th Ranger regiment as well as from
other branches of Special Forces and The
Wider U.S army the team wasn't told by
their Commander whose identity was
classified where they were going all the
information they were given was only the
essentials just that there was a high
value Target holed up in a safe house
although they had no idea there would
actually be two only the second was
unlike anything the Deltas had ever seen
Agent Lane was watching over hidden
infrared cameras they were sent to cut
out the minute the lights came on no
point in going through all this trouble
only to see 096 on his feed and be
killed too silently using all the skills
and stealth that they had been trained
in the squad of Delta Force operators
slipped into the safe house their
movements were perfectly synchronized
practiced hours and hours at a time they
checked Corners two would sweep one room
with a building whilst two more
protected them and none of them would
move on until they confirmed that the
area was clear floor by floor they
worked their way up the building
ascending closer and closer to where the
hatchet was The Operators were fully
expecting to meet arm resistance from
the hatchet's Loyalists when they
arrived the fact that the place was so
quiet didn't seem right in fact none of
the lights were on either the Delta
Force unit needed to wear night vision
just to navigate their way around
despite its seeming suspicious none of
them could have guessed it was
intentional agent Lane had set
everything up to work perfectly arriving
at one room the Special Forces troops
could hear the sound of someone behind
the door their voice was muffled like
something was obscuring their mouth and
preventing them from speaking this was
it the team lined up against the nearest
wall and placed an explosive charge on
the door with a mighty explosion the
entrance burst wide open and the team
filed in weapons trained on the room's
Soul occupant they could see through the
hazy green of their goggles a figure sat
in a chair no restrained to a chair with
something in front of him it looked like
a frame a photograph and a frame who
sits in front of a photo in the dark
suddenly the lights came up causing the
operator's night vision goggles to beam
bright white straight into their eyes
the second the lights came on the
camera's agent Lane was watching through
cut off and he purged the hard drive
they were connected to leaving no
recording no evidence of the situation
he'd engineered meanwhile as the room
was illuminated the first of the Delta
Force Team to take off his goggles saw
who it was tied to the chair it was the
hatchet Bound by his wrists and ankles
eyes pried open so he couldn't look away
from the framed photo in front of him a
photo of
scp-096 suddenly within the blink of an
eye the tall slender creature had
appeared in the room with the captive
terrorist the Deltas removing their
goggles turned in horror to c096
slaughtering their target and the moment
they looked at it the Wailing shy guy
started bearing down on them too contact
their Captain yelled open fire hostile
contact fact they started shooting their
bullets having little effect on the
looming wiry monster as it came at each
of the squad one by one the muzzle
flashes eliminated the oncoming anomaly
those brief glimpses of it flickering of
gunfire made it look all the more
horrifying screams filled the room
echoing through the building as scp-096
decimated the team that had unknowingly
been sent in to kill it one of the
Deltas was still struggling with his
night vision unable to detach them from
his face thanks to a clasp that had
gotten stuck all he could hear were his
Squad mates around him being killed but
with no way of seeing what was happening
private private the captain gurgled he
sounded hurt but the operator couldn't
see how badly or what had attacked him
shoot the thing shoot it now I
yelled back goggles still strapped to
his face eyes shut to keep out the
Searing whiteness
the captain replied directing his
subordinate to Amos weapons slightly to
the left there was a sickening twisting
sound and the captain's voice cut out
the private fired his shot winging the
creature it whimpered then seemed to
vanish as quickly as it had arrived
pulling a combat knife from the sheath
on his belt the operator was able to cut
the strap keeping the goggles over his
eyes when his vision cleared he looked
around to see an empty room smeared in
blood even the hatchet hadn't survived
killed in the chair he'd been held in
the operator took a closer look at the
photo the terrorist had been made to
look directly at it was hideous tall and
thin arms that looked too long and a
huge mouth and now it was behind him it
would never stop killing anyone that
looked at it some say that
scp-2102 was a mistake an Abomination
created by an accident of Medical
Science maybe those people are right
maybe there is much more to it than that
either way they don't know the full
story how could they they weren't there
they weren't there all the way back in
1972 but Dr Pavel zukal was Fearless
moments the events that directly
proceeded
scp-2102's creation began on March 2nd
the wind was carrying an unforgiving
freezing bite with it as zukal made his
way to the Institute of experimental
medicine zissov in Czechoslovakia with a
cold war between the USSR and the United
States underway there was already an air
of secrecy on both sides Espionage and
intelligence gathering operations were
rampant bringing with them paranoia and
distrust there was no way of knowing if
someone was a double agent leaking
information to the west but while the
governments of Russia America and their
various respective allies and enemies
scrambled for control and had masked
obscene quantities of nuclear arms in
secret there were even more cogs turning
he hidden in the deepest darkest Shadows
the SCP foundation's long-standing
rivalry with various other groups of
Interest was well known among any with a
high enough security clearance most of
these groups were radicals or outliers
despite possessing knowledge of
anomalies or even being directly linked
to them a lot of gois were independent
of any world government but for decades
the foundation had been aware of a
directly competing establishment
effectively a parallel of their own
organization on the other side of the
globe they were known as Gru division p
a USSR equivalent of the SCP Foundation
themselves it is unclear based on what
was recovered from Dr zukal's Personal
Diary if he had been directly scouted by
Gru division P for their project in
Czechoslovakia given the air of secrecy
engulfing the USSR at the time it is
possible that Pavel himself had no
inclination that division P was even
involved in the project due to take
place The Institute of experimental
medicine he might have suspected but
with no way of knowing for sure
similarly there was no way zukal could
have known where the project would lead
what he would have a hand in creating
the initial few weeks after his arrival
at The Institute were Rocky to say the
least zukal along with a team of
scientists and technicians working on
orders direct from Moscow had to contend
with unreliable equipment and difficulty
getting electricity to power the project
eventually after clearing those initial
hurdles testing could begin but what was
the goal of this mysterious project well
through zakal Gru division p and the
Kremlin were chasing something the
scientific world has been trying to
accomplish for decades something that
could change the very landscape of not
only the Cold War but the entirety of
modern medicine the secrets of cellular
regeneration unlocking that wood in
theory enable them to create the world's
very first unkillable super Soldier and
hey it definitely wouldn't be the
craziest secret operation carried out by
a world superpower during the Cold War
the CIA spent Millions turning a cat
into a listening device and training it
to infiltrate enemy headquarters this
so-called acoustic Kitty was struck and
killed by a random van during its first
mission compared to that a cell
regenerating super soldier was
positively sensible with a worldwide
nuclear arms race already underway
perhaps the Project's ultimate goal was
to produce an entire Army of these
self-regenerating troops with something
like that in their hands the USSR would
have the manpower to reinforce their
nuclear Arsenal and potentially even
soldiers capable of surviving and
healing from the effects of an atomic
blast on the 5th of May 1972 the first
of the Project's human test subjects
began to show promising results they
underwent physical trauma at the hands
of zukal and the other scientists only
for their bodies to react much faster
than the order healing process would
allow rapid clotting took place in the
affected areas preventing the subjects
from bleeding out however this quickly
went awry the clots turned into severe
lesions realizing this had occurred
thanks to Macaulay one of the other
project scientists administering too
much neodymium zukal chastised his
colleague vowing him to drag him to
Moscow personally if another mistake
like that ever took place again
unfortunately by the last few days of
June Dr zukal and his team were no
closer to success every subject that
underwent testing succumbed to the same
necrosis reducing the amount of
neodymium had only made the reaction
worse something paval couldn't allow
macali to know without the risk of it
being held over his head for the
remainder of the project in every
instance the doctors were able to
trigger rapid cell division 50 times
faster than that which occurs in the
ordinary healing process of human beings
but the biggest drawback was that this
division would quickly become
controllable it was creating enough new
matter on a cellular level that it would
choke each test subject in its own
excess waste as you might expect Dr
zukal noted this in his diary that this
process wasn't a pretty sight come in
August 1972 the project scientists
decided they needed a test subject with
more resilience than the average person
and a suitable candidate was provided he
was a counter-revolutionary who had been
sentenced to 15 years in a uranium mine
as a punishment detail despite such an
extended period of time under the harsh
conditions of the mind and the close
proximity to a radioactive element such
as uranium the man managed to survive
unscathed upon closer examination this
new guinea pig referred to as x-16 had a
rate of healing twice as fast as that of
an average man perhaps it was a random
genetic abnormality that made x-16 this
way or maybe it was a result of his
extensive time in the uranium mines
either way
made him the perfect new subject for
zukal's experiments initially subject
x16 preliminary testing results looked
promising the wound healing process was
actually taking place now instead of
resulting in necrosis or aborting it as
it had with the earlier experiments in
fact doctors who calls seem to think
x-16 was healing almost too quickly but
nevertheless testing continued although
not without a different type of problem
the questionable morality of what they
were doing began to set in for Pavel
causing him nights of endless tossing
and turning unable to sleep as he
reflected on what he'd done x-16 had
managed to survive for much longer than
the earlier test subjects but it was
clear that the torture this man had to
endure was exacting a heavy toll every
day the doctors would lacerate him time
and time again recording the results and
every day he survived only for the cycle
to begin again the next day for his own
part zukal was conflicted on the one
hand the results of the testing were
proving successful lasting far longer
and working far more effectively than
they had in the past and yet on the
other it came at the cost of one man's
continued suffering to make matters
worse a valid no way of voicing his
concerns to any of his team any
questioning of his orders or the
Project's methods would have been viewed
by Gru division p and the KGB as
sedition and treason earning the good
doctor a one-way ticket to a gulag or if
he was lucky a clean shot to the back of
the head from an agent's pistol often
morality is sacrificed for the greater
good in the pursuit of the advancement
of science or a nation's goals but now
that the project was showing results
with x-16 now that it was real what they
were doing still weighed heavily on Dr
zukal's conscience then on October 15
1972 the final piece of the puzzle
seemed to become clear by introducing
the correct amount of stabilizing agent
into the serum they had cockted zukal
and his team had perfected the
composition upon administering this
newly completed version of the solution
the doctor noted in his diary that
subject x16 was responding well at least
medically the subject was responding
well it was clear that the continuous
experimentation he had been subjected to
was causing uncooperative behavior in
x-16 but so close to the cusp of
achieving the Project's goals Dr zukal
was quick to cast aside his previous
doubts about the ethics of their methods
they were so close to Victory so close
to the project being over that it no
longer mattered how Cooperative x-16 was
being but two weeks and four days later
just as the project was nearing its end
goal disaster struck mu Dr Elena orakova
was one of the scientists on zukal's
team who had primarily helped when
examining the early cell divisions those
that were leading to necrosis and
causing test subjects to produce too
much excessive genetic material Elena
had made a startling Discovery and
immediately brought it to Dr zukal in a
distraught show of panic the cell
samples they had used to test their
serum were now gaining mass seemingly
from nowhere just like the earlier
experiments the effects were working
almost too well causing an overabundance
of cellular regeneration to the point
where the cells couldn't stop producing
masses of waste genetic material when
zukal brought Elena's findings to
doctors sizzlard and one girji t fadinko
the project heads assigned by division P
they were quick to disregard it as an
error determining to press on with a
project to meet their deadline over the
course of the following weeks up to late
November zukal was trying to determine
what was causing this change it was
clear that unless he and Elena could
resolve the issues with the serum
subject x16 would be a total failure but
time was running out with their
superiors at Gru division p and the
Kremlin expecting results by early to
December under untold amounts of
pressure and subsequent stress Dr Pavel
zukal found himself losing time unable
to sleep to the point where he was
drifting off whenever he was on the
verge of a breakthrough by the end Elena
was the only member of the team trying
to help him methodically figure out what
had gone wrong the deadline for the
project arrived on December 2nd 1972.
Pavel didn't sleep all night leading up
to it knowing he would have to present a
functioning super soldier to GRU
division p in the best case he was
risking being accused of negligent
failure forced to restart the project
from scratch making his months of hard
work redundant but worst case scenario
zukal could be charged with treason for
having not completed the task he was
selected for on the 2nd of December he
wrote I really don't know which is
better the model is a big tool nobody
knows if Dr pavel's Who called lived to
see that tomorrow his final diary entry
was made on the day
scp-2102 was born for months the SCP
Foundation had operatives embedded
within the Czechoslovakian government as
part of innumerable Cold War Espionage
Gathering efforts during that time their
agents had gathered enough intelligence
to make the foundation aware of a GRU
division P Project based at The
Institute of experimental medicine and
that the scientists there were looking
to unlock the secret of Rapid cellular
regeneration someone possibly even one
of zukal's team had managed to
infiltrate the project and had leaked
documents to the SCP Foundation
explaining what was going on in
Czechoslovakia the plan was that the
foundation would move in in secret of
course to extract and contain test
subject x-16 in January of 1973. that
day would never come to fruition though
on the 2nd of December only a month
before they had planned to act the
foundation became aware of a catastrophe
occurring at The Institute of
experimental medicine one of their
agents in Czechoslovakia alerted them to
a disturbance that had caused civilians
and scientists alike to run from The
Institute in fear for their lives
something had gotten loose and the
foundation had to act fast luckily a
reconnaissance team was stationed in
Eastern Europe members of various mobile
task forces who had been spying on Gru
division p and the rest of the USSR
moving quickly the Recon team was
deployed to Czechoslovakia led by a
field commander named Merrick that were
given the objective to determine the
cause of the situation and if possible
recover its anomalous Source Merrick and
the Recon team arrived on site to the
institute's grounds the entrance to the
bunker which had been housing the
project was left wide open with not a
soul in sight as the team progressed
further Merrick couldn't help but notice
a pungent smell permeating the labs and
offices that they passed Foundation
command urged their operatives to
proceed cautiously and recover any
paperwork they could among the
logistical documents was a diary
belonging to one of the scientists
although the name pavel's call on the
cover was no longer legible forever lost
the further he and the other MTF agents
progressed the worse the smell got they
located an elevator deciding to take it
down to the lower levels of the bunker
one by one the team filed in Merrick
radio in command command any seismic
activity in the area he asked uh not
that we know of Merrick came the
foundation's reply why I uh I think I
just felt something moved down there the
elevator had barely descended a foot
before it hit something stopping in an
instant as Merrick tried once again to
contact Foundation command that same
something came tearing through the
elevator floor over the radio the SCP
Foundation were treated to a cacophony
of screeching tearing metal along with
the screams of their own men but Marek
and his team had encountered may have
once been a man perhaps someone
subjected to Cruelty and torture but now
all they saw was an amorphous flushing
Mass immediately the Recon team opened
fire engaging what they assumed was a
raging monster it probably never
occurred to them that they might have
just wanted to be free after years of
imprisonment followed by months of
horrendous experiments minutes later
Merrick was able to get in contact with
command again locked in a heated battle
with the entity but every round fired
every shot their guns landed nothing was
having any effect whenever Merrick dealt
damage to the creature part of it seemed
to grow faster and faster each time
their guns were useless unable to stop
the expanding monstrous test subject
even grenades thrown by the MTF
operatives causing multiple explosions
did little to stop the entity in its
tracks listening in over the radio
knowing they had few options left the
SCP Foundation dispatched a pair of f4
Phantoms long-range supersonic fighter
jets equipped with a payload of m47a1
Napalm incendiary bombs with
americanismen almost on the ropes
command issued an order to retreat they
fled the bunker only to field the ground
shake beneath their feet the monster had
breached the top soil still coming after
them Jones one of the foundation's
agents was Pulled Under the encroaching
shapeless Mass crushed to death as it
continued its Pursuit utterly horrified
at the sight and speed of the creature
Merrick started begging command over the
radio to get its fighter jets to the
scene six minutes later the sound of
twin turbine engines shot through the
air followed by the whistle of bombs
careening down towards the ground in a
second Merrick his team and the creature
were engulfed in a fiery explosion the
heat proving enough to cauterize the
fleshy abomination's expanding tissue
ever since December 1972 The Entity now
designated as
scp-2102 has been housed at site 122
contained by the SCP Foundation they
keep it in a modified cell restrained at
all times with its hands and feet and
padded sleeves this is done in order to
prevent the risk of injury either
accidental or intentional given both SCP
2102's anomalous properties and its
self-destructive Tendencies its body is
covered in scars both from its previous
Escape attempts back when it was known
as subject x-16 and from burns from the
F4 Phantom's Napalm payload these
particular injuries seared the entity's
ears mouth and eyes closed rendering it
def mute and blind if scp-2102 ever
suffers any form of external injury its
anomalous properties will trigger the
creature as you might have guessed
possessed an advanced form of cellular
healing able to regenerate from all
wounds inflicted on it however the
process was never perfected it still
works too well so well that scp-2102
cells don't know when to stop instead
they continue producing bodily tissue
expanding its mass into every available
space without a halt the process can be
slowed if an obstacle is introduced
boxing in the exponentially growing
tissue however any object or person in
path is eventually crushed under the
mounting pressure at present the
foundation still has no idea how much
scp-2102's tissue could expand
potentially even posing a risk to the
entire world if left unchecked there is
only one Surefire way to stop the
creature's healing they can only be
halted by cauterizing the open wound
with intense heat it's literally a
Surefire solution
scp-2102 is a result of the good Dr
zukal's work combined with his and Gru
division P's willingness to put aside
their morality they didn't create an
undying regenerating super soldier for
the USSR as they had intended instead
all they accomplished was turning a
tortured man into a monster an
Abomination endlessly tormented by the
experiments performed on him not quite
as useful on the battlefield is it the
war that ended the world started on
October 9
1971. tensions had been brewing for
years between America and the Soviet
Union and even though people had done
their best to keep a sense of normalcy
everyone was wondering when the cold war
that had been brewing for the past 30
years would boil over there were those
who had been preparing for it for years
While others assumed that it would never
amount to anything neither Nation wanted
to make the first nuclear strike and
even if that happened the engineers
would come out of their underground
cities to intervene but nobody knew for
sure of the two World superpowers could
ever come to an agreement or if it would
all end in total Destruction October 9th
was the day that question was finally
answered the first American nuclear
warhead detonated over the Gulf of
Finland only a few miles away from the
city of Leningrad where people were
going about their day blissfully unaware
of the destruction that was about to
befall them first came a city-wide
blackout as the power grid was bombarded
with a huge surge of radiation that
caused bulbs to blow and wires to low
like they'd been struck by lightning
there was barely any time to react
before the next wave hit a white hot
flash so bright that many of those who
couldn't get to cover were blinded the
third Wave by far the most destructive
was the force of the explosion itself
like a powerful burning wind it swept
through the city breaking Windows
knocking over street lights ripping the
leaves off trees and bathing every car
building and person with Ash people are
trapped under the debris as some of the
city's older less well-maintained
buildings come crumbling down even
though the Soviet government had been
preparing for this day to come and the
Russian people had been put through
mandatory safety drills no amount of
practice or planning could have prepared
them for the real thing the streets
erupted into chaos cars were crashing
into buildings either because their
drivers had been Blinded By the Light of
the distant explosion or because the
initial wave of radiation had shorted
their batteries people knew nearly
trampled each other trying to get to
underground shelters as police and
military tried to yell directions over
the cacophony among the crowd of family
desperately tried to stay together Arena
and Nikolai bellatrov held type to their
children Alexi and Tatiana the whole
family was still in their pajamas and
barely had time to get their shoes on
before they started rushing towards the
neighborhoods designated underground
bunker Arena had Tatiana who was only
too clutch tight to her chest and
Nikolai tried his best to keep 10 year
old Alexi's eyes shielded as they walked
past the dead bodies of people who were
once their friends and neighbors it will
be all right soon son Nikolai said as
much as to try and convince himself as
his son were going on the ground just
like in the safety Thrills Alexi nodded
solemnly and kept his gaze Straight
Ahead they were almost at the end of the
street when just above the sounds of air
raid sirens and screaming people Alexi
heard a familiar voice
the boy looked down to see his teacher
Mr Petrov trapped in the wreckage of his
car he must have been driving to work
when the bomb struck father stop Alexa
yelled tugging at his father's shirt
sleeve that's my teacher we have to help
people he won't make it to the shelter
the soldiers will help him once everyone
else is in said Nikolai Alexi didn't
listen he wriggled free of his father's
grip and ran to where his teacher lay
pinned under the wrecked vehicle Nikolai
was calling after him and though Arena
wanted to wait for Alexi to come back
she was swept up in the tide of people
and separated from her husband Mr Petrov
was crying thanking Alexi for coming to
his Aid as Alexi got closer he saw there
was blood pooling out from under the
wreck it seemed if Mr Petrov were going
to make it out his legs would likely be
badly damaged Alexi tried to lift the
car himself but even though he was
strong for his age he was still only a
child a soldier had been helping people
into the bomb shelter stopped what he
was doing and ran over to Alexi hey
the soldiers shouted leave him alone and
go back to
young to hurt yourself Alexi kicked and
struggled Against The Soldier's grip as
he was dragged back into the line with
his family but he he's in trouble Alexi
cried it's not your job to save him his
father scolded as he took his hand and
led him down the stairs where they would
rejoin his mother and sister as Alexi
and his father descended into the
tunnels Alexi heard a gunshot from the
street above though he would survive
long after that day he never saw his
teacher Mr Petrov again he never asked
his father about what happened the
velotrop family was reunited in the
underground shelter which had once been
an underground train station Tatiana had
started crying and Nikolai tried
desperately to quiet her Arena hugged
her son so tight he felt she might
squeeze the life out of him they were
packed in with a dozen other families
some they knew and others who were
strangers Alexi recognized some of the
other children from school and saw that
some were there without their parents
while they were in the station a soldier
addressed the group and explained what
would happen next the train station was
to serve as their temporary shelter
until the proper negotiations were made
with the engineers as per a treaty that
had been written and signed after the
second world war the engineers had
agreed to open the borders of their
underground civilization to humans
fleeing from a crisis above ground once
the government had made a decision the
survivors were to be taken deep
underground where they would live until
the war was over above ground the Soviet
Union began dealing with the Fallout of
the initial attack it was clear that
America could no longer be dealt with
reasonably if they were willing to bomb
one of the ussr's biggest cities though
the bombing had cut Communications
between Leningrad and Moscow eventually
contact was re-established and the Army
was able to radio the Kremlin with a
full report on the damage Leningrad was
in ruin with over a third of the
population dead or otherwise too wounded
to move underground those who had made
it underground were receiving treatment
from everything from broken bones and
blindness to radiation poisoning in a
word it was chaos Russian in Parliament
was quick and ruthless and their
decision to strike back on October 12th
secretary Brezhnev authorized nuclear
missiles to be launched at both New York
City and Washington DC Millions were
killed and just like in Russia the
survivors retreated to underground
America didn't go down without a fight
though and launched another missile
attack this time at Moscow it wasn't
long before both countries allies were
involved in the conflict as well with
missile strikes coming from France China
North Korea Germany and the United
Kingdom within a month the surface of
the Earth was dangerously irradiated and
any humans who were still living had
retreated underground but though the
world had ended the war had not Alexi
belletrov and his family struggled to
adjust to their new life underground
though the engineers were intelligent
and human-like their world was so
different from the world Alexi had lived
in for the first 10 years of his life he
barely ever saw them the engine
Engineers were nocturnal sleeping while
an artificial sun nourished the
genetically engineered plants that grew
around the city but anytime he tried to
ask questions about them he was met with
hushed Silence by the adults the
engineers were spoken of in hushed
almost reverent tongues they were the
beings that saved Humanity yes but they
had also helped build the weapons that
led to the war in the first place Alexi
barely had any time to settle into this
new life before what remained the
Russian army started looking for new
recruits reports had come in from an
above ground Scout that the Americans
were working on a new type of armor that
could fully Shield the wearer against
radiation and the Soviets could not
afford to be outmatched when their army
was still recovering from multiple
nuclear attacks but the Army wasn't
asking for able-bodied adult men to
enlist they were looking for children we
can't possibly send our son to war Arena
said arguments at the dinner table had
become common in the bellatrov family he
would not be going to war Nikolai argued
not until their new anti-radiation
technology is perfected he won't be
ready until he's an adult how do you
know that what they're making in those
labs won't kill him Arena said do we
really want to trust these underground
Devils with our son how much do we
really know about the engineers anyway
they could have let us all burn on this
surface Nikolai said but they didn't I
think we should trust them I want to go
said Alexi I should some of my friends
have already enlisted both of his
parents were stunned but it made sense
to Alexi he wanted the war to be over
and he wanted to leave the underground
city but most importantly he wanted to
know if anyone was still alive on the
surface if there was even a sliver of
chance that it could be habitable again
he wanted to find out after much
discussion Arena and Nikolai agreed it
was what was best for the future of
Russia and ultimately the future of the
human race Alexi's parents delivered him
to the office of Army Recruitment and he
was taken by a man named Commander
volkov to a specialized research
facility this was when Alexi met an
engineer for the first time the engineer
was tall and hairy like a bear walking
on its back legs but with face and hands
more like a human's it was overseeing a
group of humans and other Engineers as
they tinkered with machines that Alexi
couldn't even begin to guess the purpose
of will not be Freight in the Lexi
Commander volkov said they're going to
explain the procedure to you before you
have to agree to anything the engineer
looked the boy over then held up ajar
containing something that looked like an
insect's exoskeleton it was green the
same shade as the ussr's army uniforms
this is a new bio-organic armor
prototype the engineer said we can only
graph it onto you while you are still
growing it must grow with you starting
on your back then moving to your limbs
then your head Alexi was frightened by
the idea but didn't want to seem weak he
wanted to make sure his father would be
proud of him he was taken into surgery
where the team of Engineers and human
doctors grafted the plate of bio-organic
armor onto his spine once the surgery
was over he was wheeled into a recovery
room where he was fed a simple meal
alongside all of his friends and
classmates they had all gone through the
same procedure over the next eight years
Alexi and his comrades went through the
painful process of growing their
exoskeleton like the engineer had said
it grew with them but the growth
happened in painful spurts rather than
gradually the worst thing about the
armor was that it couldn't be removed
but it gave them many advantages to
normal soldiers as well once it covered
Alexi's legs he found he could jump
higher and run farther than any human
normally could when it grew over his
arms it gave him increased strength by
the time he was 18 it had covered his
head giving it a fly-like appearance but
also granting him stereoscopic vision
and the ability to hear radio
Transmissions without the need for any
other communication device during this
time he and the other boys were trained
by Commander volkov learning how to use
the powers granted to them by their
exoskeletons for combat when they were
deemed ready they were all outfitted
with shoulder cannons Supply packs and
guns all of which were also bioorganic
and were surgically attached it had been
eight long years since the end of the
world and Alexi was now able to set foot
back on the surface the world he
returned to was almost unrecognizable
there were no signs of life outside of
weeds and Vines overtaking the
irradiated ruins of buildings within the
first hour of returning to the surface
Alexi gave up any hope of finding
survivors he heard volkov's boys barking
orders through the suit there was no
time to reminisce about the past the
soldiers had a job to do want an anomaly
of your own check out scpswag.com for
high quality SCP merch now go check out
scp-2273 major Alexi bellatrov and what
actually happened to Major Alexi
bellatrov
scp-2273 tail for more from the story of
this interdimensional Soldier